That good luck with the yellow brick
road.
Yeah.
That's some good songs.
Oh yeah.
Dude.
The bitches back.
Oh,
and but lively's gentlemen,
shrimp raid.
Powerful Duncan trussell's in the house.
Come back.
Dr Chris Ryan looking like you're fresh
off of vacation.
Like we just pulled you out of somewhat
sale,
but as on a fishing trip.
Perfect,
right?
Yeah.
The endless vacation.
We were talking about Elton John,
right before we start.
I think there's some Elton John Songs
that are just all time classics,
you know?
Yeah.
What are your favorite top three?
Boy,
I'm man.
Do you like Daniel?
That's the best.
That's a great song.
Rocket Man is one of my favorites.
I don't know.
I never,
I never thought about that.
Let me,
let me go over the lyrics.
You know,
that's one of those songs.
You just.
The lyrics almost become inconsequential
because the lyrics are,
oh,
this is the sound.
That song makes that song.
That song has this feeling like listen
to a song in a different language.
Right?
It's just an instrument.
It's weird when you find out what song
is about and it's the opposite.
Oh,
what does it say what it is now?
This is just the lyrics.
It's a bad or an astronaut or a lyric.
I don't think it is.
I think it's about like snorting
ketamine.
Is that what it is?
It's a space.
I miss my wife.
I missed the earth so much.
You just guessing Dunkin.
Well,
I mean we all get to interpret music in
our own way,
but for sure that's out in.
Johnny's in some hotel room is laid out
some blinds academy and he's about the
baseline is here.
It says,
uh,
during the Druggie or a,
given that it was penn during the 19
seventies drug era,
people can still see that it services an
extended metaphor comparing fame to
space travel.
Wow.
That makes.
That makes a ton of sense.
But it also.
I bet it also was about rocket travel
because Bernie top and wrote it.
Yeah,
he wrote it.
He wrote them on what a great
combination.
The two of those guys like you and young
Jamie,
very similar.
Nobody ever hears about young Jamie.
Last time I was here,
I tried to get them on my podcast.
He's,
he's alluding me really smart.
Just want to be on your crazy podcasts
out in the woods.
Can come into the van.
Jamie was on Saturday night.
That's a great one.
Alright,
for fight.
Yeah,
that's a good one.
That's a great workout.
So it's a real kind of.
Yeah,
it's like a punk.
British.
Yeah.
Saturday night Daniels.
The first time I really thought about
Spain.
It's about Daniel,
my brother.
He's headed out on the plane.
I can see the red tail lights head and
for Spain friend dying.
He's blind.
No,
it's about as blind brother interpreting
all of your messaging.
You must have a lot.
I like him less.
I like the.
What his songs are about.
You know what's interesting about this
conversation is trying to interpret with
songs are,
is very actual thing that happened when
people were trying to interpret the
stories from the Bible,
but it's basically the same thing.
We're trying to figure out.
No,
he met this.
he meant that these parables and some of
the stories that are in the Bible,
you know,
if you go to the John Marco Allegro
definition,
was it say his song was written from his
younger brother's perspective.
Got a story about a guy who went back to
a small town in Texas returning from the
Vietnam War.
Wow.
Okay.
That's Daniel.
And he was blind.
Right?
Your eyes have died,
but you see more than I.
Oh wow.
Huh?
Do you still feel the pain of the scars
that won't heal?
Yes.
Have you guys heard,
you know that song?
Summer of 69.
Jamie,
maybe you can bring this to Brian Adams
one,
and that's about like actually 68,
69.
Oh really?
Yeah,
that's what I know.
Again,
like every single one of them,
but look it up because I think the
summer of 69,
one interpretation is that's like a fuck
summer.
He had like $69 a month.
Summer.
Is that,
is that true?
Yes.
Is it true?
I
had my first real six string,
a Bryan Adams fourth album,
reckless.
Some are 69 in many meetings,
although one of them including life in
1969,
while another includes making love with
someone,
hence using the number 69 as a reference
boy.
That's not accurate the way they said
that.
It's just like the Internet
interpretation.
Sorry.
What I meant was it's like you would
never say that.
That wouldn't be how you convey your
feelings.
Like if you're writing that song like
the summer of 69 and this say.
Hold on,
go back to that please.
It says while another includes making
love with someone that is just.
That's not an accurate way.
I'm talking about 69 ing.
I mean,
yeah,
you're making love but you get crazy.
It's like there's more to it than that.
That was like the same thing as like
trying to interpret stories from a Bible
or something like that.
Like you're boiling them down like
you're trying to figure out what was
this guy actually say?
Yeah.
You know,
like literary interpretation.
It's all poetry,
right.
My favorite example of a song that sort
of mislead you.
I mean,
I really like songs were the covers
better than the original because the
person doing the cover gets what the
song's about better than the original
artists does.
I mean all along the watchtower.
Hendrix is way better than Dylan's.
Right?
Dillon actually said that,
but my favorite example in recent music
is.
Hey Ya.
By outkast.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
shake it like a polaroid picture.
Hey.
Yeah.
My baby don't mess around because she
loves me.
So just I know for sure you know,
it's real upbeat at it or listen to the
words,
but does she really want to but can't
stand to see me walk out the door.
Don't try to stop the feeling because
the thought alone is killing me right
now.
Thank
God for Mom and dad for sticking to
together because we don't know how.
It's all about how we don't know how to
love each other.
Wow.
Yeah.
Hey fellas,
what's cooler than being cool?
Ice Cold.
If what they say is nothing lasts
forever,
then what makes love the exception?
Oh,
why?
why are we so in denial when we know
we're not happy here.
Wow.
It's a really sad song.
Super Sad.
Yeah.
There's a dude who did a cover of it.
Oh,
Obadiah Parker.
See,
the thing that I really like about,
he gets it.
He gets the sadness of it,
play.
Some of that
is seen me.
I can't see the feeling because the
thought alone is,
Holy Shit,
dude.
Again,
because we don't know.
Wow,
this is fucking great.
Hey,
there's people right now screaming at
their phone.
I don't know what grade it is,
so fucking sick of your music taste so
bad.
Music tastes are so bad.
I get to more tweets about how bad my
bad
taste is in music and movies and
television and blame it on me.
Did that cut Chris Ryan?
Yeah,
I was.
I was looking at something the other
day,
some something on some video years of
comments or something and it occurred to
me how you have your audience is first
of all so large and also so mix because
you've got your fingers in all these
different worlds that you must get a lot
more hostility than someone like Duncan
or me because our audience is more sort
of homogeneous.
I would think I'm the bridge between the
meatheads and the potheads exactly.
So there's conflict and no matter which
way you go,
there's a little bit,
but the meatheads kind of get that look
if you want to go to the far end of the
extreme.
It's like the UFC fans,
but the UFC fans know,
like I'm a,
I'm a representative,
like I'm doing my best.
Like they know I'm 100 percent into
this.
This is not like I'm not like some actor
that they hired to promote this so.
But then you got all the way to the far
left which is the psychedelic people and
I got a ton of Vegan followers and
people that are really into yoga.
It's like all of them together.
It's like the weirdest fucking house
party
it seems sometimes.
The comments,
well no man,
this is like,
what is this?
This Ram das retreat that I just went
to,
one of the,
one of the people who run runs their
treat wanted me to tell it to thank you
because he's like,
you know,
your podcast brings a lot of people to
these randazzo retreats,
which is,
to me it was such a strange thing to
think man that you're magnetizing people
and bringing them down a slippery where
they
land in Maui,
hanging out with like Buddhist and Hindu
teachers.
It's really crazy,
man.
It's a very odd thing.
How many?
Like how many tentacles you have fucking
burning man.
Jesus Christ.
Burning man.
Everybody wants you to go,
man.
You've got to go.
You got it.
Go.
When is it again?
It's like it's all coming season.
Late August there listening.
He can't bring some elks to burning man.
I can't interact with that.
Many people do that anymore.
Those days are done,
but you know what?
What has changed?
Like a big.
One of the biggest thing that's ever
changed because of this podcast.
The float industry.
Yeah.
Floating streets taken off.
I get like residual gratitude from float
places like I know you know Joe Rogan,
you can float for free.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Well,
the thing is,
it just didn't make any sense to me that
before I was talking about it,
no one was talking about that this was
something that was invented by Lillian.
What?
Nineteen 60 something happened where you
were vertical know he had one where you
would wear a helmet and you had a
harness and helmet with float you,
you know,
and then he figured out the salt thing
and um,
I mean the fact that this was not a
popular thing was blown me away.
Well it was,
but then it died because of the age
thing.
Yeah.
And you brought it back for this
popular?
No,
no,
but it was much.
It was higher than it dropped a lot.
They killed it because nobody knew,
sort of brought it back in.
Yeah.
So with John Lilly,
you know what's interesting about him,
people leave out about him a lot is he
was talking to aliens and it's an
interesting thing that people just kind
of push all that shit aside.
They know him as the flow guy,
you've in a float tank,
dolphin and the Dolphin Guy,
but also they completely leave out that
he was going into those tanks and
claiming some kind of communication with
something called the ECC or something
eco,
you know about that they're earth
coincidence control office or something,
you know about that.
Then the center of the cyclone.
Yeah,
center the,
but he was going way out talking about
some kind of like invisible I guess
network that produces coincidence is.
I don't understand it at all,
but people just completely leave that
out.
That the guy created float tanks was
using them to communicate with entities
and he was using a lot of ketamine.
A lot academy.
Yeah.
Or maybe they.
They're leaving out that the guy who
invented float tanks lost his shit there
toward the end.
Well,
he may be,
but I think that.
I don't know what's happening when
you're doing psychedelics,
but there are certain psychedelics where
it absolutely feels like you're
experiencing another life form
communicating with you.
For sure.
Right now,
if that's the case with ketamine as
well.
Ketamine seems to be like me personally,
my personal bias,
I sort of dismiss it because I think of
it as some sort of chemical compound
things,
some sort of a synthetic thing.
That man's career,
Ketamine,
what?
Something is more
reliable,
but I think that's just my own
ignorance.
I think really we're just talking about
chemicals.
Right?
And how chemicals that exist in nature.
It's like when someone says it's an
artificial chemical,
well that's not real because everything
is natural.
Everything's here.
Like it might've been concocted and put
together and baked and cooked and
synthesize by a person,
but of course it's all natural.
Everything that's exists.
Antics though,
because it isn't.
It isn't in that these chemicals most
likely have some sort of a corresponding
receptor in the human brain.
Right?
Or something similar.
Something similar molecule.
Yeah.
And it's a natural thing.
Like that's the craziest thing about the
most potent drugs,
whether it's still assignment or whether
it's dimethyltryptamine,
they have like really similar
composition did normal human
neurochemistry keys.
Like there are keys that fit a certain
lock.
That's how they put it.
Yeah.
But I do think that there is a
distinction between natural and
unnatural in the sense that something,
because I get this argument all the
time,
right?
Oh,
people created it,
so it's natural,
but there are things that exist in the
natural system,
like plastics don't exist in the natural
ecosystem and therefore they don't break
down.
They don't become part of the food chain
in a beneficial way.
Whereas things that have existed in that
system for a long time do they fit into
it and I think in terms of drugs,
there are drugs like ghb that exists
naturally in the body that we metabolize
absolutely cleanly because the liver
knows exactly what it is.
It's prepared to deal with it and it
doesn't cause any organic toxicity,
no neurotoxicity.
But then there are other things like
alcohol which are natural in a sense
that fruits for meant and all that,
but the body doesn't metabolize it
cleanly.
So it damages us in.
Particularly if you're from a very
specific part of the world,
right where it's a.
If it's not a part of your customer,
which is why it was such a giant issue
when Europeans came here,
they didn't.
They didn't have any history with
alcohol.
Well,
well,
you know Hamilton Morris,
a device guy.
He tweeted this thing I thought was
pretty smart.
Probably a little controversial.
Forgive me if I miss quote it,
but it's something along the lines of
it's drugs,
it's drugs and that word is a
controversial word.
Somehow people like to use the term
plant Madison,
which is okay.
You can call it plant medicine or you
can call it whatever you want,
but to create a hierarchy based on
synthesis I think is to sort of miss the
point which is that all of these things
are tools and some of them we have more
of a history with humanity and some of
them we don't.
The ones we don't,
which is my God,
there's so many.
There's so many new drugs that are just
popping up all the time.
Different derivatives of Lsd,
things you can like right now apparently
you can order sheets of this stuff that
is like Lsd,
but it's in the gray area.
It's still kind of legal,
it's like a different version of,
but we don't know
yet the effects it's going to have
because it's not like anyone's really
testing it out.
So I say the name because Jeff sessions
is listening at one hand as you're
writing down little southern big scary
of Jeff sessions at a giant Dick Table.
Yeah.
But anyway,
I think this talking to a woman who had
sex with a little person and she said he
had a normal sized Dick [inaudible] that
big heads.
So Jeff sessions with a normal sized
Dick would be interesting
proportionally.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I mean just scary to think about like
that jeff sessions having like some kind
of like.
Because you know,
he's such a,
you know,
he's just such a quintessential pig,
and it's like you want the
quintessential pig to have some kind of
like to be almost like a unit or
something.
But it's terrifying to imagine the jeff
sessions when he takes his clothes off
probably as like six nipples.
It was just running right down the
middle of his fucking chest.
They usually,
it gets wet when he's like arresting
people.
They who's the little goat knobs that he
has to fall file down.
Go Nazi pro.
Yeah.
He's got file private prisons.
He visits private prisons and just pulls
out his massive throbbing cock in front
of people who've been sentenced there
for life.
It's right on that screen that you put
your hand on.
Mr.
Sessions.
I was standing up for it.
I just want you to know that going after
medical marijuana,
again,
it's trying to.
It's almost like he can't help himself.
He knows what the laws are and it's
almost like I just want to grab them.
Let me just grab,
just grab them.
I know what science says,
but I've got my personal opinions on the
thing and that's what matters.
Just anytime there's one person who has
authority over another person and
they've lived an entire life in that
position.
That's their ecosystem.
Their ecosystem is they have authority,
they enforce laws,
they lock people up.
They put in this the game that gets the
game they play and be successful.
Yeah.
Not just that.
It's like there's an objective.
It's literally like almost like a
monopoly game,
like you see what the thing is to arrest
people.
You're,
you're the guy who arrest people,
you arrest people and convict people.
That's your game.
That's what you do.
You're plugged into the machine.
Do you know an interesting thing about
monopoly?
It was invented by an anarchist who was
invented it to teach kids the evils of
capitalism.
Wow.
Really?
That's incredible.
Goofy.
Anarchists are the exact opposite thing.
It's like what they do to it.
It wasn't supposed to be fun.
It was supposed to demonstrate that when
you accumulate capital,
you ended up taking it.
All right.
Wait,
what do you think?
And Arkansas.
Well,
I think that anarchistic or people who
want to diminish this system that we
have have far less rules have far less
government.
Right?
And usually they're kind of spastic and
their,
the way they express themselves is
always like very awkward
court like Libertarians.
Well,
but you know,
you know,
like I've just been reading this book
are a narco syndicate.
Realism.
It's like this,
I cannot dance.
It's really interesting to look at the
history of anarchism like when it comes
from versus what it gets interrupt
because I remember when I was in high
school or do you remember drawing the
fucking anarchy symbol and you'd be
like,
yeah man didn't even know what it made.
You're just assuming you know,
but,
but I think one part of it that's really
beautiful is the idea that we don't need
withered old prunes like jeff sessions
telling us what we can put in our
bodies.
We don't need that.
That's true.
And,
and,
and that how many jeff sessions are
there and the power structure and then
where it gets really fucking cool man.
Check out David Graber.
You should have him on the podcast.
My God,
he's fucking brilliant what you're
doing.
He's an author and he,
I'm a philosopher,
I guess you could say,
but uh,
he is incredible.
And he wrote a book called,
I think it's called the Utopia of rules
that I've been reading,
which is pretty fucking bad ass.
And it's just sort of breaking down like
the,
um,
the bureaucracy that we're in right now,
bureaucracy,
all the fucking forms you got to fill
out to do just about anything these
days,
like all these fucking forums.
It's insanity,
right?
Right.
But then where it gets really
interesting is he's right now.
So like in like communists states the,
the,
the corporations in the state are kind
of the same thing.
So there's these like Ministry of Labor,
the stores are all national stores,
you know.
And so we think that that's not what's
happening right now.
But actually because the people were
running,
a lot of the corporations used to be in
government and the people who are in
government used to be running these big
corporations.
One of the cool points he makes and also
because the government is making the
rules that the corporations are working
by,
but the corporations are putting their
own agents into the state.
He saying the actually the line between
the state and private companies is
really blurry right now.
They're kind of merging together
together.
But we like to pretend that there are
separate,
for example,
what's happening right now with the
fucking fcc trying to take away the
internet with verizon having one of
their fucking pig drones in a
superposition of power right now is
trying to take away the freedom of the
Internet.
The state can be like we.
The corporations can blame it on the
state.
It's just clarifying by what
you mean by that,
because they're not trying to take away
the freedom of the Internet to try and
to try and get rid of net neutrality.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So what did it mean is that you will
have to probably pay more.
Yeah.
To access things that require more
bandwidth and it's going to be.
It's not.
It's going to be what it is now where
every website has open access it you two
versions,
right?
You get the capitalist version.
I think it's a good idea,
and then you get the tech version,
which thinks is terrible idea.
I almost
always go towards the tech for.
Yeah,
but that's the Anaconda.
You know the way an Anaconda kills
somebody,
every time you exhale it squeezes in a
little bit.
That's all.
Like right now,
it's the squeeze in as,
okay,
this fucking Internet.
It sucks.
If you're somebody like jeff sessions,
that's not.
That's not where the money's coming
from.
I think you're misinterpreting the whole
idea.
It's all just a business thing.
It's like being able to throttle the
data and being able to decide like,
like if Netflix wants you on there,
if you want to have netflix on the
network,
they want to be able to work out some
sort of a deal.
They don't want to treat netflix like
it's any other sort of streaming
service.
Like you look at it,
the,
the business transactions.
So they're looking at in a business
sense,
they're not saying the internet sucks.
No one is trying to like squeeze the
Internet,
stop it with the trying to do is make
more money.
Well,
okay,
great.
They're trying,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
I do here.
I do know what you're saying,
but I think it's a slippery slope and
it's that idea of the Internet being
treated like,
I don't know,
water,
the Internet being treated like just a
thing that no corporation should have
any kind of say that that to me it has
to stay like that because the moment
some corporation,
whoever it may be,
it gets to start deciding,
yeah,
you guys need to pay a little bit more
and if we establish that corporations in
the state aren't as separate as we like
to think,
then suddenly there's all kinds of back
channels there.
Suddenly there becomes a new way to
begin to filter out content and you
could say it's for money.
You start building financial walls
around things and you start making
things vanished into the background
because they aren't in some big
conglomerate that's paying off the
corporations more or whatever.
You just mess up the whole thing,
which as far as I can tell,
it's doing great.
The Internet.
Great.
This fucking compound you're in right
now,
you know,
a lot of it came from the Internet.
This thing we're doing right now,
it's the way the Internet's been
working.
Oh Dude.
No one's a bigger proponent of the
internet than I am.
I just think when we're talking about
these issues,
you've got to be.
You've got to be really like objective.
What's trying to happen here.
They're not trying to silence dissent.
They're just trying to,
trying to make as much money as possible
and this is a weird tricky time when it
comes to information and we do have to
be very careful because it could wind up
being like,
Hey,
you get your internet from comcast will.
Comcast is no longer allow,
you know,
Blah Blah Blah.
The laugh app that has your podcast
featured on it or you know,
some new streaming service.
It's yet to be discovered.
That will be in the future.
Challenging Youtube.
So youtube gets together with Google,
you know,
they're owned by Google and they get
together with verizon and they make it
exclusive for the verizon network.
If you want to get on youtube,
you have to be on the verizon network.
That's,
that's.
This is all inside the realm of
possibility.
Fuck.
The deeper level though,
anybody who thinks that government has
not been totally captured by
corporations isn't paying attention.
I mean,
that's not news in this country.
You come from Europe where this is one
of the things,
the problems I have with anarchists and
Libertarians.
I think they're very naive about what
the world would
look like if there were no government
regulation.
Yeah,
I agree.
Every poison,
every river would be to poison,
to swim in it.
You know,
the air would be fucking because
corporations,
it makes sense for them to dump their
shit as near to the factory as possible
and don't give a fuck about birth
defects and dead people that it doesn't
matter.
That's true.
But a lot of good things come from from
that,
from a lot of anarchistic a theorists
and and,
and some of those things.
Well,
I think a lot of it relates back to my
shit with a hunter gatherers because
hunter gathers are essentially anarchist
functioning anarchists.
The problem is when you scale up and
you've got corporations that,
you know,
I've talked about this on this podcast
before,
what my idea that my belief that
corporations are living things,
institutions are living things and their
agendas conflict with like super
organisms are.
Sounds Spooky.
I think that every time you get large
groups of people together and they
operate under one window or one
umbrella,
rather,
they just tend to act like one organism.
Just what countries do.
I mean,
listen,
it's a natural thing that human beings
do for some strange reason,
not only human beings,
right?
Think about flocks of birds and fish and
yeah,
and hills.
There are all sorts of examples and then
you go the other direction are,
are a microbiome,
you know,
I mean that's all functioning according
to its own systems,
you know?
And then that's happening within us.
So there's all sorts of scalable stuff
going on.
I think you'd be insane.
Did not think there needs to be some
kind of structure to help things
function smoothly.
But I think we all agree we don't need
as much structure as we've got right now
and a lot.
But the problem is.
Sorry to interrupt,
just to finish the point,
I think what happens is a lot of people
get in their heads and they start
thinking that the state is responsible
in some way or another for their
wellbeing and that.
And that's what happens is you start
forgetting that if what's really
important is communities.
What's really important is finding a
group of people that you love and
deciding in this group of people
loosely,
it's not a commune.
It's not like a cult,
but just deciding what the group of
people that you have making this really
intense decision,
which is none of us are ever going to be
homeless.
You could start there.
That used to be what the family was,
but a lot of people don't have that
anymore.
So groups of people agreeing very
loosely to take care of each other and
in a way that the state is currently
functioning with welfare and all that
shit.
That's to me is like,
it's not anarchy,
but it's a.
it's a sense of soul,
like shrugging off the idea that the
state is really going to take care of
you,
but what if the state is an expression
of that sense of community as it is in a
country like Denmark for example,
were Danish people and Dutch people and
Swedish people and you know,
lots of northern European countries
said,
you know,
we're not gonna.
Let anyone be homeless and suffering.
We're not going to let any children be
malnourished in this country.
We're going to take care of each other.
It depends on how
it.
It's.
If you're.
If there was a pure expression,
if for one,
if the people are unified enough to
create a pure expression of what they,
what they're like central goals were,
that would be pretty startling to me,
but if we pay lip service to America all
the time,
you know,
thanks for your service and we're all in
this together.
We're all Americans.
You know,
rally around the flag.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what we're doing.
We're,
we're trying to create this sense of
community.
We're all in it together,
but when it comes to actually taking
care of each other than we don't do it.
Well,
I mean that's to me.
I mean the list.
Let me say them as natively stupid
thing.
I was just thinking about this in the
way ever.
I mean this is so dumb,
but I was really thinking this because
you know,
the prisoners are fighting the fires
right now,
you know,
that is that prisoners.
They're getting paid $1 an hour to fight
these fires were there.
It's fucking insane.
But I was just thinking to myself like
dollar,
no $1 an hour.
But I was thinking to myself,
man,
what,
what if like everybody in California was
like,
shit,
there's fires and we all were going to
help fight the fires would,
would we all be able to put the fires
out?
Like if like as many just people just
started flooding to actually go help or
if like all these homes are burned down
and I was just thinking like,
shit man.
If like everybody in California is like,
all right,
let's just go help them build their
houses back.
I mean,
it's so insane,
but also fall apart if you are building
a house,
trust will start building out.
They'd be like,
no,
nothing's done.
Nothing's the fuck did you do.
I wouldn't be in charge of the.
I wouldn't be in charge of building the
fucking houses.
Like sandwiches.
I make sandwiches,
which is another cool thing that I like
about.
I'm not saying by the way,
I'm not a fucking nras but one cool
thing I like about the idea is like
right now we have this hierarchy of uh,
you know,
of have like careers,
right?
So doctors are valued more than somebody
who plumber,
plumber,
right?
Or plumbers are plumbers are valued more
than like,
I dunno,
a house cleaner or something.
So like,
you know,
it's considered a low status thing if
you're somebody who works in a fast food
joint or something like that.
But when you get together with a group
of people who are fucking cool,
some people are good at some things and
some people are good at other things,
but nobody is valued more than the other
person because everybody loves each
other.
And you've got this,
like what,
you know,
the person who's the most,
like somebody digging trenches to like
put electrical wires down,
a pretty unskilled job is super
appreciated because who the fuck wants
to dig the trenches managed when you add
money to the equation,
which is what we're doing right now.
And I get it.
I'm not saying get rid of money or
whatever.
When you add money to it,
everything gets fucking weird.
So what I'm saying is it's just a right
now when we hear about the fires,
we think,
okay,
I'll donate some money,
I'll donate some money.
That'll,
that'll do it.
I'll donate some money.
But this is,
like I said before,
it's crazy naive.
I just had this image
of like,
fuck,
what if just huge groups of people
started going towards the fires in blood
cells,
contaminants that.
Yeah.
Because right now we're using prisoners
will do you understand the terrain?
Like this is not something that most
people can traverse.
You're talking about like extremely
hilly areas that are also you.
You'd have to be not just fit,
but you'd have to understand which way
the wind's blowing.
You could get shoe horned in and
surrounded by fire.
There's a lot of like serious dangers
with them.
It's a beautiful idea on paper.
We need trained.
There'd have to be like.
It would never.
I know it never fucking happen.
It's just clear.
You would need a lot of stuff.
Someone would have to organize.
It was supposed to be bigger than this
than the city of Washington DC.
Now I know how big the fucking bad.
I mean it's insane how big it is.
It's terrible.
You'd have to get a lot of fucking
people to circle that bit,
but we're just so.
We're so.
We're so broken apart.
We're so disconnected.
Like whenever you hear about something
going down,
it's just a thing that's going down.
If someone's house is burnt down,
your that fucking house burnt down,
that's it.
You don't really think much more than
that and we think the state is going to
come in and like take care of everything
and I think that's what the state wants.
I love using the term this state.
Does the state want that or is just how
it's structured now at wants it,
but the state wants to because in the
same reason anyone who's in an abusive
relationship wants to be in control.
It's like if you think that I'm the one
who's going to help you,
then you're dependent on me.
And do you think if the.
If there was a really effective,
massive volunteer firefighter force,
the state would resist that?
No,
I don't.
That's what's beautiful about it is I
don't know how the state would resist
that.
I mean we do see the state resisting
things like groups of people getting
together and trying to feed the homeless
and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Rather they resist last popups and you
can't feed them like that.
There's a lot of licenses you need
licenses to feed people.
You got to fill out forms baby.
But isn't that.
Would that be a good idea to prevent
people from poisoning people or people
giving them bad food or.
You know,
but I mean,
I don't know for sure man,
but when was the last time you heard
about like an organized group like food?
Not Bombs poisoning.
Homeless people wouldn't have to be
that.
It would be Duncan's food delivery
service,
so you just started out.
You might might have good intentions,
but not really be qualified to prepare
food.
People are eating fucking hamburgers at
a trashcan.
Definitely better than what they're
eating.
For sure.
I know the real issue with homeless
people is not just an economic issue
though.
The one of the big ones needs to be
addressed as mental health and when they
changed the standards during the Reagan
administration,
they essentially just sent people out on
the street and they were using Duncan.
The argument you're making basically,
which is that the state is providing for
people.
They should be.
There should be private church
communities,
religious based families.
That was the argument they made.
I think it was disingenuous.
I think it was just about taking money.
Yeah.
No.
This is about giving it to the whole
Reagan thing.
What we're seeing now is the fruit,
the bitter fruit of the Reagan
Revolution.
They're still using the same economic
arguments that's trickled down.
Shit.
Yeah.
That was started.
I most listeners probably aren't old
enough to remember this,
but I remember in the eighties,
David Stockman was the,
the economic advisor did Ronald Reagan
who came up with all this stuff.
Four or five years later,
he left the administration.
He came out and said that was all
bullshit.
We knew it was bullshit.
It was just a story we made up.
It has makes no economic sense.
It's ruining the country.
I'm so sorry.
Jesus Christ,
you know,
and but they're still using it because
it's a narrative that's effective.
The,
I'm getting into this a lot recently,
like how narratives are popular and
powerful,
not because they make sense,
but because they create a story that
justifies the power structure that's in
control at the time.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
this is,
this is why I think it's like hyper
important right now for people to find
groups of people that they love and do
more than just like play board games,
like getting together with people and
like make stuff like face the facts.
Man.
Fucking California is on fire right now.
I mean everyone thinks this shit just
stays the way it is.
It's not just on fire,
it's on fire in a way that you realized
like,
oh,
it could be twice as bad as this and we
would literally have to.
Everyone would have to flee the state
and it's December.
Yeah,
this is the rainy season and it easily
could be twice as bad as it is now.
We're just mean we're in a weird place
and there's no rain in the rain is
incoming.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
like it sucks that people have to.
You have to create in your mind the
reality of what's happening to my
friend.
You know,
he was sending me pics,
he was right by the fires and he's
saying people just can't understand how
bad this is.
People just can't comprehend it to
people because this is,
this is,
this is like,
this is real life right now.
Do you guys feel like this,
for example,
and other things that are happening,
do you feel like this is the shit
hitting the fan in a way that always
seemed hypothetical?
You know,
like this is to me that we're living
through a moment that's almost like
aliens arriving in.
Like something that you always thought,
well that would be weird.
Right?
It's happening.
It's happening right now.
It's like there are things happening now
that seemed inconceivable even five
years ago,
10 years ago.
I don't know.
Like I remember what specific.
Well,
I mean like evacuate Santa Barbara on a
few times that I've thought of.
Trump president is the main thing of
course.
And like,
oh no,
these,
these national monuments were selling
them to those mining company that now
you know,
their lobbyists works for the heads of
the Department of the interior and just
like,
it's over like this.
We're reaching.
This is an end stage,
but you know,
hold.
I know what you mean.
And like God
knows like depending on how much,
how high I am,
my brain will get really shrill about,
fuck,
this is it man.
This is the end stage.
This fucking apocalypse happened man.
But man,
but then then when you go and look,
because I make some ketamine.
Well,
no,
like I had on my podcast recently,
he's said his story and the first
question I asked him is this,
is this the end of the world?
And he's like,
I don't think so.
He's like,
you know,
they go into black plague,
wiped out like what 30 percent of the
people on Earth got white.
Certainly Times that are filled with
adversity and we're,
there's a restructuring.
Yeah,
it's the,
I don't mean it's the end of the world
per se,
but it's the end of the American empire.
It's the end of America as a country
that,
um,
other,
other people around the world looked up
to as a,
as a model to be emulated.
Well,
we have a contest to see who controls
the nukes and this is the first time
that the popular guy fucked up what it
is.
And this is the first time a popular guy
entered the popularity contest.
So who knows how to be popular and
there's a bunch of people out there that
are pro wrestling fans and they bought
right in Hook,
line and sinker.
And that's.
And that's a very simplistic version of
it.
There's a lot of other people that
wanted to throw a monkey wrench in the
system because they thought Hillary
Clinton was a crook and she probably is
because they're all crooks.
There's most,
most of those people at the top,
or at least in some way fucked up.
Yes.
We have an opportunity to rebound.
Who Al Franken,
and I know Al Franken's just a but
grabber and all things considered.
Did you read the last bit,
like the straw that broke the camel's
back?
The last one where the veil said enough
is enough.
It was in the Atlantic.
This woman or he put that.
She asked for a photo.
He put his arm around.
His hand was on her waist and schools
are fat.
He squeezed her.
He.
She said he grabbed a handful of flesh,
which is a weird thing to say,
but he squeezed her at least twice is
her quote.
At least twice.
He had his hand on her waist and she
said,
I don't even let my husband touch me
that way in public because it demeans me
as a professional woman.
Oh,
you're fucking kidding me.
Let's.
I'd like to interview her husband like
you're not allowed to put your arm
around your wife in public.
The squeezer my wife would love to be
squeezed.
The more,
the more the merrier.
The idea of it is,
um,
it's very strange because that,
that one doesn't make sense to Leanne
tweet and one was the only one that made
sense.
He,
there's a photo of me.
She's unconscious.
It's demeaning,
I get the whole thing.
He apologized for that and rightly so.
And apparently he tried to kiss her but
then the butt grab and it's like,
well,
he's definitely shouldn't be grabbing
people's Butts.
But I mean,
how much of a big deal is it also do
have we stopped?
I mean,
Chelsea handler was on Bill Maher the
other night and she said,
I have to believe these women because
I'm a woman.
And I thought,
well,
wait a minute,
does that mean I have to believe all
men?
Because I'm a man the isn't there any
discussion about whether these things
are true or not?
[inaudible] Mia said this,
he said
he put it on twitter.
He goes saying all women are liars is
just as crazy as saying all women tell
the truth.
Right?
Well,
yeah.
I think a lot.
Franklin,
I don't know enough about Franklin,
but a lot of these people,
it's like,
like Weinstein wasn't like 40 people or
something like that,
like 40.
I think when it starts getting up in the
and also what?
He's accused of it.
Yeah.
In different things.
We're not talking about taking pictures
with people.
They were,
they like you.
They want to take a picture of you and
you grabbed their waste.
We're talking about.
I mean he's been accused of rape by more
than one woman,
like actual rape,
rape.
Not just like getting someone drunk and
having sex with them and be like holding
them down type rape.
There was a lot of,
he's,
there's a lot of crazy.
See here's what's kind of fucked.
Um,
if prostitution was legal,
would that exist or is it a power thing?
Is it always a power thing?
Like does he want to have sex with the
star of his films?
Because that's.
I think it's more a question of if,
if there weren't so many teenage boys
who never got laid what with the society
look like,
and by this I don't mean to excuse
anyone and I don't mean to say teenage
girls should be more promiscuous or
anything.
I'm just looking at objects.
I'm saying that guys like Harvey
Weinstein,
that Dude didn't get laid in high
school.
Most of the,
you look at these mass shootings,
a lot of these guys in their,
in their suicide notes say,
I'm doing this because I can't get laid.
I'm going to die a virgin.
That's the one begins.
Actually,
uh,
there's this a massive amount of
frustration that builds up because
biologically most boys are horny little
monsters at 13 or 14.
They're not getting laid.
And so it gets to the point.
So there may be five,
six years between when a boy is totally
obsessed with not just sex,
but with being acceptable to women being
loved by women being touched,
being caressed being,
and they can't think about anything else
and they're not getting it.
And so I think a lot of boys grow up
with extreme frustration that either
curdles into misogyny,
where you get these,
like mass killers who,
who did they kill hookers,
right?
Sexually Liberated Free Women in their
perspective.
And you get guys that just chase money
their whole lives because they think the
money and the power is going to get
them,
those women.
And so when they get to that place and
they're still fucking disgusting and
they,
they sense that the women don't even
want to fuck them or they only fuck them
because they're going to get something
from them.
Then there's all this self hatred and
shame.
I think that's what's being expressed
here.
So I think it is power and I do think
that it has a,
it's an,
it's an expression or a manifestation of
a deeply sex,
negative pathological culture.
Conversely,
how do you feel about like women that
weren't attractive in high,
how come they don't lash
out at the same way?
They're not out there rape and did one
becoming them down.
Women are much better at accepting their
sexual situation.
You see women have accepted a lot of
shit that men are unable to accept for
Millennia.
That's partly biological and probably
partly cultural,
but also because,
I mean women can have sex.
Even women who aren't particularly
attractive because the,
the,
the whole market is so skewed in the
other direction.
Even women who aren't particularly
attractive probably don't have much
trouble getting laid in high school.
I don't think it's just that.
I think you're boiling it down to
getting laid.
That's a reductionist thing.
I think it's way more,
but an unattractive woman who has a hard
time finding a boyfriend.
You know,
someone who loves her.
Someone who wants to be emotionally
connected to her.
That probably is just as children full
to a woman as a guy who can't find maybe
more painful.
Yeah.
Then a guy who can't find sex partner in
psychology,
they say that men express their,
their these feelings through anger and
women through depression and sadness.
Right?
So you probably don't see women lashing
out and killing a bunch of dudes.
You see them being depressed and feeling
like shit.
And when you do,
they have high testosterone.
That's why
another point to be made here is,
is that like,
you know,
people do say the thing,
oh well,
like people like Harvey Weinstein,
they wanted all this money to get laid,
but I don't,
I do not think that's it.
I think what people like Harvey
Weinstein probably enjoy his power.
It's not like,
oh,
I want to get fucking laid.
I'm going to become this massive.
It's like I like to dominate.
I'm a dominating force.
That's what I am.
I'm going to.
I enjoy like having people around me who
worship me and as part of that I'm going
to dominate my interns.
I'm going to dominate my employees and
when I'm around women,
I'm going to use my.
I'm going to fucking jerk off and house
plants in front.
I mean,
it's like really fucking the ficus,
but you know,
you gotta you gotTa really think about
that.
It's like,
I don't,
I don't.
I know what you're saying.
Oh,
poor Harvey Weinstein.
When he was fucking in front of the God
damned with the.
He's saying,
well,
the thing of like he's not getting
touched enough.
Well,
no,
but it's like this is the,
there's a lot of frustration that's
inherently connected to this suppressive
sexual culture that we find ourselves
embroiled in that we don't necessarily
agree with these fucking little boys.
Why are,
you know?
Because one,
that's the only access they have to.
They're less likely to tell on them.
And three,
there's self hatred.
I just recidivism.
I like to do a little thought
experiment,
which is I like to imagine what,
where my head's gotta be if I jerk off
into a house plant in front of somebody.
If you don't,
if you have tried that,
just just think about it.
Like where would you,
what's going on with you Christmas tree?
Yeah.
It might be like you're just
celebrating.
He doesn't mind if you jerk off in the
plant,
the plants can absorb it and he's just
leaving as dna all over the place.
It's really good for the planet.
Bet It is.
It's terrible for plants.
Not My.
Jim Weinstein is great for parents,
Bro.
Plants alive.
It's running for Senate Alpha Alphacam
coming soon from onnit.
Joko you can really sell your com right?
I don't want anybody,
don't you think that all these things,
uh,
it's,
I think it's certainly this sex is not
just a power thing because he's not just
exercising power.
He's exercising power in a sexual way.
Yeah.
It's not just power.
I think it's the game,
like we were talking about like
corporations and even police officers
and guys like Jeff sessions who have the
game to arrest people.
That is the game they play.
They get really good at it.
That's what the game is the game with a
guy like him is,
I can't believe I get to fuck what's her
name,
know name,
famous actress and that famous actress
is on her stomach and your mouth fucking
her.
Like,
Whoa,
really?
Is this really happening?
And it wasn't really happening.
It's happening because you're going to
let her be cat woman or whatever the
fuck the movie is.
Right?
Yeah.
There's some nuttiness to it.
There was some craziness.
There's some forbidden thing to it.
There's some,
there's a bunch of,
a bunch of things in play powers.
One of the dynamics,
it's just the most foul one because they
all the other ones like the sexual
frustration and stuff doesn't seem so
gross.
It's like when you,
when you,
you're,
you're imposing your will on someone.
Then it's unquestionably an,
an expression of power.
Like once you were raping,
once you're coercing,
once you're imposing your will and
you're saying,
I'm going to take away your career.
If you don't let me have sexual
intercourse with you,
well then it's 100 percent power thing.
Like how did it get there?
There's a lot of things and I think
you've got to get a lot of power.
I mean,
I,
I guess I haven't exercised sufficient
power in my life to know the answer to
this question,
but does,
does dominance feel good directly or is
it,
is it something that comes to you
indirectly.
So in other words,
does it feel good to dominate someone
else or only because then you can get
something that you want from them?
I think it's something that you want
from them and I think there's also,
there's I think human beings are
connected to each other in an undeniable
way and I think that if you're
exercising power over someone like say
if you hate to paint the scenario but
just save you rape someone,
you were sexually attracted to someone
you're loan with you and you raped them,
and if you have any conscience at all,
if you,
you know,
they're screaming no,
and you're still having sex with them
and you come and then after what you
have to think about it like you would be
horrified at yourself.
The level of self hatred would be almost
unimaginable.
Even posed yourself and your,
you're,
you're twisted sickness.
At the heart of that moment,
you know,
the,
the power dynamic.
Trying to impose the power.
It can't possibly feel good.
I think it's just a thing.
I think it's just a,
almost like a creepy leftover reptilian
instinct that,
that creatures have.
Because if you look at rape in nature,
and this is not to exonerate,
rapist is not to normalize rape,
but it's insanely common in the animal
kingdom,
right?
It's all.
It's common in ducks.
It's in common in all sorts of different
animals.
Yeah.
Orangutans are ruthless and it's tough
because there are a lot of primatologist
are women and they learned the hard way
from what I've heard,
that the always wear jeans.
If you're working with Orangutans,
oh Jesus Christ,
rape a tanks.
That's awful,
but this,
that this thing,
we're supposed to be evolved past that
and for the most part,
by far and above,
we are right.
If you think about all these sexual
harassment interactions,
now imagine if they were chimps,
you know,
I mean,
imagine if they were a Rangataua was the
rape is the common thing.
You could never have a bunch of a tanks
in some sort of a building and people
would go,
well,
of course we're better than a rank
tanks.
We are.
That's why we don't rape as much,
but it is problematic to use the word
rape when you're talking about animals
because part of it is that the way you
described it,
that knowledge on some level that this
female is totally not into what's
happening right now.
Whereas presumably Iranian,
Tim doesn't have that knowledge and also
there are animals where the female is
triggered to ovulate by aggressive male
behavior that we might call raping.
Right?
Like rabbits.
You bite the back of their neck and
that's what makes the female ovulate.
Well,
that's.
There's a lot of weird stuff when it
comes to women's w,
what,
what is sexually attractive to certain
women and what arouses them?
Rape fantasies is the number one.
A lot of women like to be choked,
you know,
like what's happening.
They're like,
why?
Why do you like to be choked?
Why do you like to get your arms pinned
behind your back and why do you like to
fight back?
Like you actually like it.
You want me to do that?
You want me to hold both your wrists?
Okay.
You're sure,
like there's a lot of tying up going on
out there.
There's really.
Yeah,
there's a lot of people are.
like this is all very strange stuff in
your apartment,
but here's the thing.
When it comes to like s and M or bondage
at one,
I think one of the big misconceptions
when it comes to that is that if you're
being tied up or if you're tying
somebody up there,
there's like anger happening in that
situation.
It's one of the most sweet,
loving,
trusting things that you can do for you.
It's the.
It's really like,
I don't want to say full easily sell it
it.
It is.
I've spent,
I spent a lot of time in dungeons.
Actually.
It's a healing sweet,
beautiful thing.
There's a difference between that and
rough sex is very rich.
I mean I personally find it not,
not.
It doesn't turn me on at all largely
because it's so choreographed.
All the outfits and the this and now
we're going to do that and safe words
and.
Yeah,
but I mean I have been in those
environments and as Duncan says,
it's,
it's like the opposite of out of
control.
It's totally in control.
Totally worked out the difference
between a gun range and a war.
So funny.
Well the last time I was at a gun range,
I ended up bleeding from the head.
What happened?
I was with my buddy justin and we were
shooting,
this is up in Washington state where I
was shooting his uh,
remember what a 30,
30 or something and sculpt he had.
He had this big elk gun that he was
trying to scope in and he was like,
man,
I'm not like,
you're shooting really well,
can you just take a shot at a few shots
on this and see if you.
And I just grabbed it and didn't think
that it was a totally different gun.
Yeah.
And I just went boom in the scope,
went right into my forehead.
All these macho dudes,
you know,
I'm,
I'm exposed as the idiot range.
We went to shoot at burnt down.
Did you hear about that?
No,
I would imagine it did.
I would imagine it now.
Well,
recently,
yeah,
there's definitely fires in that area.
I mean the fires are so out of control,
especially that out towards Santa
Barbara and Ventura,
Ventura,
and that's the worst.
You know what I keep thinking?
What if the fucking big one hits like
shit's gonna catch on fire on the big
one heads and all the roads are going to
be fucked up.
The infrastructure is going to be messed
up.
That like this is like without a massive
earthquake.
What happens if the big one hit right
now all the water lines are broken.
Trucks can't get there.
Yeah,
yeah.
It could be a giant issue.
Then you have toxic clouds and stuff
too,
because all these warehouses going.
Not only that,
if the big one hits,
it's entirely likely.
It's not just going to hit here,
but it also hits in the ocean.
Which case we get hit with a tsunami.
Which case all that super expensive real
estate in Malibu just gets wiped away.
I'm good up in Topanga though.
Yeah,
you're probably,
if you're not good up in Topanga.
We're really.
Yeah,
we're fucked.
Yeah.
You're like a canary in a coal mine.
Calculate the planet,
leave it to me,
dude.
Get back to the topic you're talking
about.
It's the,
what's the thing that's happening is
people are realizing staff that nobody
ever really wanted to talk.
Shit's changing.
Like if you,
if you ever watched like porky's or if
you watch any of the movies from the
seventies,
like the makeout scenes,
like
the guys are like,
come on baby,
come in here.
What are you doing?
They're like throwing themselves on.
They're doing things in movies that were
just considered like,
yeah,
that's how,
that's I guess that's how it's done.
You're like,
you are forcing themselves.
There's like scenes I think with like
Bill Murray maybe or scenes in the old
movies with all so many of them.
Uh,
pepe Le Pew,
you know what I mean?
There's 100 percent right?
See,
when you,
when you're seeing like this,
like you're seeing much French.
Yeah,
it's crazy when you go back and look and
you realize like,
shit man,
what's happening is moves from the
fifties where the guy will just grab the
woman and things are changing is what's
happening.
And,
and,
and as things change,
like the two things we need to figure
out,
number one,
we have to admit like,
yeah,
I get it man.
Like,
you know,
for me,
like hanging out with you doing the
podcast with you.
I know.
Here's one thing I know man,
I'm pretty sure at least you don't want
to fuck me.
I'll tell he didn't look at me when he
said it was just totally left out for
the chapter and your next book,
but you know,
Research Duncan with,
with,
with what's happening with women is a.
because a lot of dudes and I,
I'm sorry if this is a shocking thing to
say,
a lot of dudes are in positions of power
and what's happening with women is like
who want to be actors.
You're wanting whatever you want to like
do it,
do stuff when they're getting around.
These guys,
they don't have that assurance.
They're not like,
this guy doesn't want to.
They're probably thinking this guy wants
to fuck me for these are women who most
guys want to fuck.
Yes.
So especially
if you're talking about Harvey
Weinstein,
these hot actresses,
right?
The,
the real.
The strange thing is you have that
unquestionably.
Yeah,
and then you have women that want to
have nothing to do with that part of the
business.
They don't.
They're not trying to be seductive,
they just want to work.
They want to act,
and then they have to deal with all this
bullshit.
That's it.
But then you've got women who sneak into
that mix and they're willing,
not only they willing,
they're manipulative and they're
seductive and they.
They're trying to make their way up the
ladder.
That way they exist there.
It's a much smaller percentage,
but they exist to make sure that their
whole society is set up to make women
think that the only thing they have to
trade is their sexuality.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with these women agreeing to do a film
with not even Harvey Weinstein.
Anyone.
And then he says,
I'll give you more parts if you fucked
me.
And the girl wants to do it.
And she does it.
Like,
I think it's gross,
but it's not gross.
It's not gross to her.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's.
It's a weird thing.
It's only grows if it's gross.
It's gross being around a guy like
Harvey Weinstein.
Right.
If he's yelling at people and he's fat
and sweating all over the place,
it's.
Yeah.
Unless
it's not gross.
Unless you like that kind of guy.
Right?
Like you might bears.
Yeah.
Because they're into bears.
Might you might like that.
Yeah.
Right.
So at what point are we.
Are we taking away women's agency when
we say that?
That should never be.
You shouldn't be able to give a guy a
blow job and get a part in a movie.
It's weird.
Right?
It's like you should be able to pay for
things,
but you shouldn't be able to pay for
things with sex.
Why not?
That's George Carlin's things.
You can buy things when you can have
sex,
but you can't buy sex.
Like it's strange.
It's strange because I don't think it's
necessarily illegal in a barter sense.
Like say it to you dinner,
like say if you had some woman and she
wanted to paint your house,
but in it is a bad example or you wanted
to paint her house,
how about this?
She wants you to pay it,
they're going to pay you but I will suck
your Dick and you're like,
okay,
that's a deal.
Like that seems like a good deal.
Like you want to do that?
And she's like,
yeah,
I want to do I want to talk to your dad
because I also want you to paint my
house.
I mean look at some girl.
It depends on who it is.
It's Angelina Jolie and she's 25 to be
out there with the fucking roller.
You just be thinking.
I was going to take a long time to
finish though.
I like if you're both into it and this
is exempt.
And again,
again I have to be super clear about
this,
but I'm not exonerating rape or sexual
harassment or predatory behavior.
What I am saying is we have a weird.
It's weird that we separate commerce
from intimacy when it comes to sex and
it's the only type of intimacy you can
get massaged in your underwear.
I do it all the time where women will be
talking to me about,
you know,
well,
my kids go into school at this place and
he really likes wrestling,
but the problem is they're discontinuing
the program and while they're doing
that,
she's digging her elbow and my back and
I'm in pain,
but I'm,
I'm in my underwear or alone in a room
with this lady and I'm having a nice
conversation with her while she's being
intimate with me.
I mean,
that's essentially what's going on.
There's oil involved,
they're massaging neck and it feels
really good.
It's don't shoot any fluid out of your
body.
We allow that to get a woody when you're
getting a massage.
Uh,
it definitely moves.
I'm trying to stay calm and zen though I
put myself in,
in a peaceful place.
Fucking worse.
When your deck starts getting harder and
they're getting a platonic massage and
you're like,
what were like preparing your apology?
But it's because being touched.
We're also touched a starved.
Yeah.
You know,
in this society that I think people have
a hard time distinguishing between
pleasant touch and eroticism or between
good sex and love.
You know,
we mix it all together because we were
so unfamiliar with it.
There's also,
there's would be levels to prostitution
to right,
like what would be a peek ahead buddy.
You don't have to tell us what would be
the problem with someone who say was a
woman who just did not have
a desire to have a family like to
freedom.
Didn't want to work a regular job,
but she likes having sex with men that
she likes.
So she picks a few men.
Maybe she's got a small roster of like
10 guys who fucker and they rotate.
No,
you can do Tuesday.
Mike's doing Tuesday.
Okay.
Wednesday.
Yeah,
Wednesday at work.
This is happening.
There's a lot of this.
I just was visiting with a friend of
mine who does this real.
Yeah,
there's a website,
I forget what it's called.
It's not friends with benefits,
but it's their websites and there's a
whole name for these sugar daddies and
sugar daddy sites where the guys now
it's like,
okay,
look,
we're gonna.
And the way she described it was,
there's no,
it's no set price.
It's not like a thousand bucks to fuck
me or whatever.
It's,
it's like we get together if I like you
have dinner,
whatever.
And Yeah.
And then you want to get together again
next weekend.
Okay,
you want to take me to Malibu?
we'll go to Malibu and then his money
showing up in my accounts or not.
And if it's not then I'm deciding do we
want to keep seeing this dude for
nothing,
you know?
Or it was 150 bucks,
And then it's like,
and she's like different guys depending
how much money they have,
they give her more or less and so she
can just decide at anytime.
She wants to continue the relationship
and she doesn't consider herself a
prostitute.
And you go to someplace like Thailand.
It's,
I met this dude in Nepal years ago who
explained to me the whole do the whole
deal because I've spent a lot of time in
Thailand,
but I've never been able to wrap my head
around and I was Horny as hell,
but I couldn't wrap my head around the
thing and how it worked because,
you know,
getting back to your rape thing,
to me the most demeaning experience in
the world would be to find myself in a
sexual situation and realize that the
woman doesn't want to be there.
You know?
It's like,
oh my God,
that's just like,
I feel so ugly,
you know,
so to be with a Thai woman and there's
all this confusion and she doesn't.
She's acting like she wants to do this.
Anyway,
this guy explained to me,
he goes to Thailand,
there's a woman he knows there.
If she's not around,
she'll hook them up with a friend of
hers,
but basically he'll travel with her for
a month or to take her all over
Thailand.
She translates,
she gets them better deals on rooms and
food and everything.
She knows what to order,
and Thailand is very cool about
prostitution.
It's Buddhist that doesn't have this
anti sex thing that we have,
so it's no big deal,
right?
As far as the Thai people are concerned.
And um,
and at some point on that trip,
they'll go to the village where she grew
up and they'll meet her family and he'll
be like,
hey,
your mother's refrigerators looking kind
of old.
Is she needed a new refrigerator?
Oh,
that would be great.
And they go buy a refrigerator and give
it to the mother and the mother.
Super happy.
And that's the,
that's it.
There's no money changing hands.
It's a gift.
So it's very much like what you're
describing.
It's and sex.
It's not for the sex.
There's sex,
there's friendship,
there's translation,
there's saving me money and telling me
the best places to go.
That's like a guide.
And sex is just part of that.
It's a very,
it's,
it's hard to conceive from our cultural
perspective,
uh,
that it actually works that way.
I don't think there would be anything
wrong with a woman deciding to have sex
with a bunch of men for money.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with it or I think the real is comes
into having sex with somebody you don't
know.
Right.
You know,
if you're a street walker and some guy
picks you up and wants to kill you,
that's the real danger.
The real danger is not in your clientele
unless of course one of them is a
fucking psycho,
but I think can happen on a tinder date.
Yeah,
I think we are.
We're operating under the echoes of the
puritans and uh,
I think as grown adults deep into our.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm 50 now.
How old are you?
Fifty five.
The idea that we're still under and
you're 43.
Imagine being under this.
The whims of some people who died,
you know,
hundreds of years ago,
had a complete ignorance to human
psychology,
to physiology,
to sexual urges to genetics.
They did.
What they knew then is literally
flavoring the way we behave today.
It's so insanely suppressive.
It's good point.
I also have a point about all this
sexual harassment stuff that's
uncomfortable and this is those
environments become your world.
If you're in an office eight hours a
day,
that is most of your day.
Yeah.
Most of your waking conscious day you're
spending in this one area and people,
they start behaving like that's the
world and you start becoming sexually
attracted to the people that are in your
world and some people reciprocate and
some do not.
Some people are frustrated and some are
not and some people are gross and
they're in a position of power in that
weird world and I think maybe that guy
wouldn't sexually harassed in the big
world,
but in this little world where
everything's jammed in together and you
have these clearly defined things like
this guy has got a plaque on his desk
that says the boss.
Right,
and you got to come in and he's got the
desk.
Come on and shut the door.
Shut the door.
Or if you like Matt Lauer,
you've got a button where you lock the
door,
click fuck.
Come on.
Inside.
We've got to discuss.
We've got to review your progress.
This click,
this is the world,
I mean,
I'm not exonerating.
Matt Lauer can't believe I'd say the
scan,
but if you're in that guy's world and I
don't even know what he did,
I didn't pay attention.
I met him once.
He was quite a gentleman,
but he's in this.
He's got to be working 10,
12 hours a day.
You're doing the today show.
It's insanely competitive that morning
TV thing.
You have to be on the ball,
you have meetings,
you have fucking stuff to review.
You have guests.
Are you going to review your performance
in your conversations with people and.
Well,
Matt,
you know,
whenever you start talking about sex,
people drop off.
Look,
we've got the numbers.
We have the chart in the direct relation
to what you were saying earlier is what
I read about Matt Lauer was,
uh,
he,
he
couldn't have sex with a,
just normal people because he's famous
and he's,
you know,
he'd get in trouble and he's married.
So he had to maintain the facade of
that.
He and he couldn't have sex with other
famous people because that would come
out into the press.
So he had to have sex with people who
weren't famous,
they weren't just normal people.
And that left the office.
That was it.
So imagine if we lived in a world where
we said,
who gives a shit if Matt Lauer's fucking
someone other than his wife,
that's between them.
The sixties,
again,
this,
I don't know that that was back when
Dustin Hoffman was grabbing titties
acute,
and if you guys ever seen,
by the way last,
sorry the last word on this for me
anyway,
the people who are acting shocked and
outraged around Matt Lauer and Charlie
rose are full of shit.
That's what.
That's what kills me.
The hypocrisy of the people who've been
working with them for years and going,
oh,
I had no idea.
I heard about Charlie rose being a
fucking creep 15 years ago and I don't
even work in media.
You know,
it's like the bill cosby thing.
Open the bill cosby thing was an open.
Have you see?
Have you guys seen this?
Is one of the grossest things you can
witness in a workplace is when the boss
starts giving fucking neck rubs.
You ever seen that?
A neck rub and boss though it is,
it is so fucking creepy to watch a big
fat fucking boss saddling up behind some
married secretary.
Just so how are you doing the day carol
rubbing her neck and she could see the
look on her face frozen.
She's got kids.
She's.
If she says to him,
Hey,
do you mind?
I don't really want you to touch me
right now.
He's going to be,
oh,
I'm sorry,
but then she doesn't know down the line,
down the line when he's doing employee
reviews and he's thinking,
you know what?
Ruin that fucking time.
I just wanted to rub her back,
man,
but I'm not rubbing any of the dudes
backs in the office.
Now that man that is fucked up.
That is one of the sleaziest slimy.
His things and to imagine when you're
the boss,
to imagine that these bosses,
they're oblivious,
they just don't know.
They just want to give them that
corrupts.
They're not aware like come on.
They can feel that it is.
He's rubbing their back.
If you can't feel their fucking.
Adam's trying to escape your sweaty God
fucking male.
Dominator.
How many guys become friends with women?
Have Air tag friends just so they just
creep and closer,
almost like your stock and big game and
you want to just move real close to flow
and that's what they're doing.
One of the classics.
That's how I hunt elk.
I walk real slow.
Give it an echo now.
Don't give it a try not to make my
intentions known.
That is what's happening in these
environments.
I think when people work in offices
together,
they get attracted to each other.
Whitney.
Cummings has a fucking hilarious bit
about it.
I won't.
I won't do
it justice.
I'm not going to say it,
but she talks about working in an office
because she's,
you know,
she works on Rosanne.
She's on.
She's on the staff,
like she's in an office all the time.
She's like,
this is what people do that it's this
weird environment and office romances
are fucking.
There's so calm and they're so common.
Plus together they're going to be
attractive and if you're.
If you're married to some guy and he
said he's the big boss and it says that
on his breastplate,
the big boss and the big pause as a
secretary with the big ass and big tits
and she's friendly and he's alone with
her all day,
all day,
every day,
every week and she's calling it home
because she's on top of the appointments
and she's made.
Is his playing.
Oh,
I have Mike's flight arrangements.
I just wanted to call it and the wife
has to listen.
Listen to this bitch
hanging out there.
They slowly taking her power away,
socking away her influence until one day
can't take it anymore and he's like,
you know,
just fucking.
Is it home?
If Carol was like you,
Carol doesn't understand me.
Carol is just such a bitch to me.
Sometimes it's,
it's crazy because you give her so much.
She provide her so much.
She,
she doesn't know any woman who want to
be in Carol's place.
You know me.
You work with Carol doesn't understand
me.
Next thing you know,
you've got the sexual novelty kicking in
when he's been banging carol for 15
years.
They got kids,
they got a mortgage,
they've got a big ass.
Yeah,
to Nice.
That nice with Ruby red lipstick and her
long nails.
Well it's fucking.
The whole thing is just like I've office
fucking and all that.
Just like the whole thing is kind of
unsavory.
But like the and yeah,
for sure.
Office Romances,
I hope they do happen.
Hope everyone in the office is,
is happily fucking all day long.
That's glory.
But man,
when you think about that much work
done,
when you think about fucking being
denise and who's this dude's name?
That Guy Mike.
Mike,
Tara.
When you're fucking didn't hear denise
and you got this job and there's Mike
and Mike is a fucking asshole man.
Mike is not.
You're not as different story than my
story.
Yeah.
No,
I thought Mike just had a lot of
responsibility,
but I thought mix a big burly guy maybe
eat a little too much and drank a little
too much company or sanitation motto.
Lot of work responsibility and Mike
smells like fucking onions.
It's far.
It's or like his mind.
It's farts are just fucking hell.
A should see denise's ex husband,
man.
Denise has a kid,
has a kid with a guy who was a real
piece of shit.
I'm saying what's happening right now,
right now,
what's happening is there's been a lot
of fucking slimy massages that have been
going on.
I'm going to guess for about 5,000
years.
There's been a lot
more than 20,000
years is slimy massages.
It's been building up like the fucking
yellow stone super called there and in
the fucking like epigenetic Dna of
women.
There is probably somewhere in coded in
there,
just millennia of creepy fucking
massages that don't stop with the
fucking massage depending on what time
period you're in.
You know,
and so I think that what we're feeling
right now is the result of generations
of creepy fucking massages and much,
much worse happening.
And women are like,
fuck this,
this fucking sucks.
We're sick of it.
We're fucking sick of your creepy
massages and that's what it is.
And some women,
I mean,
imagine man,
I've.
There's one time at a blockbuster video
used to work at a blockbuster video.
And My boss was this like,
just a,
a sleazy fucking like just a slimy
fucking gay dude.
I didn't like him.
He made his clean the video tapes when
they didn't need to be cleaned.
It's like,
come on man,
these tapes are clean spray and fucking
videotapes down.
I remember late at night,
he,
we,
there's like the area where the cash
register is,
is this closed off cubicle place?
I'm,
I'm down.
I'm down on my fucking knees,
man.
Having to get something from underneath
there.
And this dude like hops up on the
fucking counter and he stretches his
legs out in front of me.
He's like,
spread eagles is fucking legs out.
So like blockbuster khaki pants on
curling up.
But you could see the outline of his
fucking boss balls in there and,
and like.
And he's like,
he's like,
you got.
I mean he's,
he never.
There was nothing more unappealing than
boss balls accentuated by Khaki.
And you're looking up there and he's
looking down at you.
That power has been accentuated.
He's looking down at you and he's just
saying you did a good job today.
He did a good job today,
Duncan,
and I'm like thinking like,
this is fun.
This is truly got to be one of the
circles of fucking hell right now
because like,
this dude is hitting on me right now.
I'm getting paid minimum.
You for sure dude.
His legs are spread.
I don't know.
Can I put it in just doing you?
Can I prove it?
Yeah,
for right.
I don't even think people were doing
yoga in North Carolina at this time.
If he was a woman,
you would assume that those actions
would indicate that she would want
sexual intercourse.
I'm saying there was a feeling now
whether I could prove it or whether it
was just me or whatever.
Oh,
what?
twenties.
I don't know,
but there was a feeling that this sucks,
man.
There's more going on here.
Right?
This sucks.
That's.
Is it a legal.
Is it like,
could I.
is it even sexual harassment?
No,
but it sucks and it's like it sucks
dude.
And that,
that,
that is the,
is what a lot of fucking women had been
dealing with for a long time and they're
pissed and they're rightfully rightfully
fucking pissed.
It's like,
who wants to be dominated like that?
If I'm getting dominated,
I want to be paying for it.
You know what I mean?
I don't want it.
No,
no doubt man.
Um,
I really do think there's something to
this idea that humans aren't meant to be
in these small areas totally enclosed in
together with each other all day.
I don't think we're designed for it.
No,
I just don't think that's an intimate
environment.
As weird as that sounds.
And this is not saying that men and
women can't work together and be
totally,
you know,
platonic.
And they absolutely can.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's a super unnatural behavior,
unnatural environment to be in these
cubicles.
You small little boxed in offices
working day in,
day out with people,
smelling them.
And you know,
I think we should outlaw offices.
Yes.
We have to get shit done.
Working at home,
a kiss for it
solutions,
but definitely protected by the state.
The state man who's going to fix the
roads,
we could fix the roads.
We'll figure it out.
We were talking about something earlier
that I wrote down because I wanted to
remember it.
You were saying about Bob Dylan's
version of all along the watchtower
versus Jimi Hendrix.
I think Jimi Hendrix was amazing,
but Bob Dylan's was his and he wrote it
and it was something cool about.
Listen to those words.
Even it wasn't like as pleasing orally,
but there's a.
If you go to cat power official,
you know cat power is saying she has a
video up today that she put on her
instagram.
She's got a great instagram and a video
up today of Bob Dylan in the 19 sixties
in Paris,
getting all these really dumb questions
thrown at him and he's doing like this
press conference and he's sitting there
smoking cigarettes.
He looks like he's like 25 years old and
they're yelling things at them and
asking them questions like,
what did you find it?
Yeah,
pull it.
What?
Listen to this.
Listen.
It's kind of crazy,
man.
Do you agree that you should be the
leader of singles with a message is
don't you attend your first breakfast
one that's better than the ones that you
do now?
You said that he's American American.
Well,
that's why you probably did better is
because I feel like singing off on each
particular special to express.
When you're saying no folks
kind of weird,
Huh?
Yeah,
I'll fucking weird French,
but how weird is that?
Like seeing this is essentially like the
same dumb questions you'd get on
twitter.
Yeah.
Twitter accounts would get those exact
same student.
Take your oldest dogs better than.
You'll see that there's some performance
art is to hired a security for himself
and a cameraman and he walked through
times square pretending to be super
famous and they had other people like at
the periphery studying the crowd
reaction to this staged famous person
walking through Times Square.
Here,
we're seeing this.
No,
I forget.
I wouldn't.
I don't know how to tell Jamie to look
for it,
but it's incredible.
They interview people,
right?
Who have seen him in there.
These two huge black dudes and a guy
with a camera and he's like walking
around like he's,
you know,
fucking superstar and they interview
people around is this Damn Jamie,
you are fast.
So this is him by himself.
Normally I guess security with a suit on
and security and I remember they asked
people like,
what do you think of whatever name it is
a.
and one of the dudes was like,
well I really liked his early stuff and
this was not one of the guys that was
paid off.
This is another person on the street.
It's just making it a random idiot.
Yeah.
That's so hilarious.
Well,
I've had that happen to me before.
Will someone come up and ask me for a
picture?
And then another guy will pull out his
phone and go,
who are you man?
I'm like,
I'm nobody picture.
It's like getting a camera.
I'm going to get a picture with you too
if I know who you are.
You don't know who I am.
So why would you want a picture window?
That's crazy.
Just don't grab his waist when if you.
If you double pinch my fat,
I will call it shit.
Double Pinch my family.
You've done tens of thousands of photos
after your shows.
You always stand out there and you take
a photo of every morning.
Oh really?
Weird man.
Shows got too big.
Yeah,
like the Belko theater.
I just didn't tell you.
You're doing really big.
Yeah,
it's too bad news.
I'll do it still at the ice house and
stuff like that.
But sometimes people,
they have an agenda and it's not just to
say hi,
you know,
and they just want to monopolize.
Not Monopolize your time.
They don't care if people around you and
you're run to those people and you don't
know what.
It's just too much work.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
Did that,
man.
That was crazy.
You did that.
That was,
that's crazy.
I remember thinking,
man,
it's a lot of times shannon out there
did it for 3,700
people.
Add like an extra couple of hours to.
You're there for two hours.
Yeah.
A second show.
Literally.
Did you have a fucking immune system on
fire?
Because when you think of all those,
like when you think like if like we
could take your hand after shaking three
people's hands.
So
there's never that many people with is
3,700
people in the theater.
100.
It might've been a thousand.
Take your hand and if we could put it
under like a scanning microscope,
you know.
How much shit do you think is on your
hand after one of those nights?
Probably like a pretty lots of shit.
Lots of stuff.
Lots of com.
Com pitfalls.
What sweat shirt or sweater?
I just like it.
It's got to be some period blood on my
hands.
Some fight.
And who knows man.
Maybe like pizza,
pizza,
[inaudible].
A lot of weed.
Some we'd never know.
People try to slip it into your pocket
or something handed to me.
They put it in my hand.
I was telling I can't.
First of all I get too much weed.
So anybody trying to get me,
we'd please don't give me any weed.
I get too much wheat.
And then second of all I can't.
I don't know.
You can just take your weed.
Just can't.
I can't,
I wish I could.
I'm sure you cool.
You know.
Sure you are.
But I have kids.
Somebody gave me.
Somebody gave me Iowasca after a show.
I'll just drag it right there on the
spot.
It was a,
it was a tough.
It's a tough with black.
Oh Geez.
It's IOWASCA.
I remember taking it back to my towel,
looking at it and for a second thinking
like what?
What would happen if I drink Iowasca and
a fucking holiday inn.
Like how bad would that trip be?
Be fucking wonderful.
The ceiling would open up to be
propelled right through it.
Yeah.
It's the same stuff that William hurt
drank in altered states,
bro.
This is the real shit.
I got saved in a tupperware.
Just shake it first dude.
Once,
once,
once I got it,
I got home after the show I've flown and
someone had given me this framed picture
and I have this frame picture.
I don't remember what the art was.
It's like a skull or something.
I wasn't somehow like I ended up pulling
the thing open and inside the picture
was a fucking joint.
The guy had shoved a joint into the
picture and I had flown with it.
So if they had,
if they had like seeing if they'd open
that shit up,
they would have seen a joint and I
would've had to been like,
Nah man,
somebody gave that to me to show it was
fucking hippie shit.
Dumb ass trying to smuggle one joint.
So it's dangerous.
It's tricky,
man.
You can really get in trouble.
Had An interesting experience recently
at Heathrow.
I don't know if.
Did you want to talk about this in New
York?
Anyway,
I was flying through Heathrow and uh,
I had a connecting flight,
miss the connecting flight,
but whatever.
There's another one two hours later.
So I'm going through security because
you have to like go again through
security at Heathrow when you're coming
from outside Europe.
And uh,
I'm standing in their way and they take
my bag for a secondary check and,
and I see the woman talked to the boss
and he says,
we'll use the other one over there.
So she takes my bag over to this other,
a security line that's not functioning.
And she runs it through the machine
there.
She comes back and they talk for
a minute and he comes over to me and he
says,
you and I have to have a conversation.
I said,
okay.
He said,
um,
what do you do?
Like writer,
psychologist?
And he's like,
yeah,
but what do you do?
What hobbies do you have?
Hobbies?
And I literally,
I said,
dude,
I'm 55.
I jerk off and go to bed.
I don't have any hobbies.
He didn't smile and he's like,
you have a garden.
It was like,
no,
that you work with animals.
No.
Like,
I don't know,
like fertilizer or something.
Fertilizer residue got on your brain.
They use that for bombs.
So he's a surgeon,
right?
He's like,
well,
you haven't told me a story that makes
sense,
so I have to call the police.
I was like,
what are you talking to me?
He's like,
well,
night night,
a nitrates set off the machines,
shut off the other machine.
They're never wrong.
You're going to have to sit down right
there and wait.
And he tells this other guy,
watch him.
Don't let him go anywhere.
Like yeah,
I'm gonna make a run for it,
and he threw and these cops show up
dude,
and they were like nine cops and body
armor like surrounded me and you know,
it was like,
wow,
this is what it feels like to go down.
But you are also a 55 year old white guy
who's obviously well educated.
You're not speaking with a weird accent.
Exactly.
That's what I'm thinking.
So if it,
if I were black or you're whatever,
for me,
I would've been terrified.
Did you see the video that I posted to
the guy that got gunned down?
Watch it.
I did.
So horrific.
Unbelievable.
It's a murder.
It was murdered.
And also why do you have to crawl across
the fucking floor?
How does they put your hands over your
head and we come over and cuff you
because they wanted to clear the room
who's near the room.
They didn't want them to be too close to
the room.
The room was slightly around the corner,
but the way that guy escalated it was
playing a game of Simon says with them
and I will fucking shoot you.
And then did shoot him for just reaching
back to grab his pants.
His pants were falling down.
It was as he was crawling,
I mean was.
He was in no way,
looked like he was doing something
dangerous.
But the most fucking disturbing thing
was how many people in the comments
after I posted that video on twitter,
we're saying,
you know,
that he didn't comply.
They were like saying clean kill.
He didn't comply and clean,
clean,
kill.
Come on,
come on Joe.
That's a clean kill.
And also one that the guy was drunk,
he was young.
He's,
you know,
it's an open carry state by the way was
white.
Yeah,
he was white.
He had.
This is not an agency if the guy that
killed him.
Monster.
Scary looking dude,
man.
Jamie can you.
I'm fucked.
Written on his Ar.
He fucked your for your,
for your friend.
And then I should say I'm fucked.
And then the other thing was they didn't
let the jury look at the video.
They thought it would take them like it
would change their opinion.
Like what are you talking about?
Reality.
To see that video,
that video is,
there's the guy,
what the fuck Jesus Christ man,
go a good beat up a lot in high school
and there's that old expression.
If you give someone a hammer,
everything looks like a nail.
That's the only tool you have is a
hammer.
Everything looks like a nail and you're
given this young guy who's obviously
fucking psycho mean the way he gun that
guy down.
I mean that was insane.
Just fucking insane.
And the idea that this represents two
human beings in an interaction and that
one human being has that much power over
the other one that he can yell at them
screaming,
I'm totally escalate the situation,
not deescalate,
you know,
and that he's got this gun out by the
way,
which you're in an open carry state.
So if the guy did have a toy gun or
whatever the fuck they said he had,
and he's holding this toy gun and
someone calls the police,
you're allowed to have a toy gun,
you're allowed to have a gun gun in
Arizona.
I read that he was state,
he was an exterminator and he had like
22 or something that he used for
extermination in the room and somebody
saw through the window him holding a
rifle,
but you know what man,
those are legal thing,
unless someone just got completely
hysterical and called and said,
hey,
the guy's pointing the gun out the
window at people and this is the message
that got in.
The cops don't know when they show up,
but when you see that guy and that woman
and you just see their fucking body
language as they're walking down the
hallway,
super casual,
they're not walking like people that are
about to kill people.
They go,
they comply immediately.
The guys begging for his life,
please don't shoot me.
The whole thing was horrific.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and so I mean this gets back to we were
talking about with the women this moment
in history where women are tired of the
sleazy hand rubs.
I think we're also at the moment were
nonwhite.
People are fucking tired of being done
down.
Everybody's.
This is a white guy,
so you know what I'm saying?
This is everybody so imagined.
Well,
but it doesn't show.
It's everyone.
It shows it.
It happens to white people sometimes.
But imagine the black guy.
I mean,
you're right.
I got in Albuquerque,
homeless dude,
and they fucking throw grenades and he
starts running.
Oh yeah,
there was,
this happened like two years ago.
There was a homeless guy.
He's sleeping right out in the bush
somewhere near Albuquerque.
And the cops come out,
they throw a flash.
Flash grenade scares the fuck out of
him.
He jumps up,
starts running away.
They got him down from the back.
They shoot them in the back as he's
running away.
And it's like.
And they were acquitted.
I mean,
it's,
it's nuts.
That is.
There's no accountability.
And uh,
so.
But the thing that I,
you know,
the,
what's the line that a thing it was
Benjamin Franklin or,
or one of the founding fathers said that
the police,
the revolution,
the revolution occasionally has to be a,
like a fed with the blood of their
history of liberty must sometimes be
watered with
the blood of Patriots.
Martyrs.
What?
A fucked up tree.
Hey man,
why you got that in your garden,
man,
that's fucking get that thing out of
your.
But don't you think there's like a
cleansing revolution that has to happen
every once in a while.
I think what we're experiencing now as
people,
well,
what we're getting from information
right and where we're getting from this
use of the Internet is the ability to
spread information instantaneously.
This video could have existed decades
ago and we've never seen it,
you know,
and there would be no need for potty
cameras back then either they didn't
have the technology.
So now they do.
Everyone has to have a body camera.
This guy did this knowing he was filming
it,
which is even more insane.
Like imagine this guy completely
unfiltered,
right?
I mean,
he might've just gone that guy down for
the fuck of it as soon as he saw him.
I mean,
he might be just a guy looking to shoot
people,
which is real.
Well,
no,
this is the thing that we're,
this is like you're saying,
oh,
what,
you know,
priests,
molesting kids.
Uh,
and why?
Well,
a lot.
I don't know why there are so many are
doing it,
but one thing's for sure sociopath's and
people who are trying to do fucked up
shit.
Wait,
what was the.
You're saying about.
What's her name?
Kira.
What was it you were saying that she
liked DP.
Oh yeah.
What?
What does he do?
So she said she.
She was joking on this podcast I did
with her.
She was like,
you know,
I think I've gained the system because
what I love the most in sex is DP and
that's what they pay the most for now.
What he being doubled penetration for
some people aren't fucked up.
Both of them.
Brand new new listeners.
What that shows.
That's a person who
figured out truly you'd figured out how
to make money doing what she loves.
And so in the same way,
when you have these fucking sociopath,
these pedophiles who want to make a
career,
we want to figure out a way to do what
they're doing while while like
sustaining themselves.
Well,
they're like,
oh,
I'll just become a priest.
If I become a priest I'm going to have.
And it's all power.
All talking power dynamics here because
it's like it's not enough the you're an
older man and you're helpless kid,
but on top of that you're a
representative of the creative force of
the universe.
You're like the fucking spokesperson for
The power dynamic there is a is it's
almost as skewed as it can fucking get
it in the same way that guy,
that guy.
No,
I mean,
you think when that guy goes home,
he's like listening to sounds of
waterfalls and shit and taking baths
with lavender candles.
That guy is.
That guy goes fucking home and he just
probably just fucking punches a brick
wall.
He just punches.
Was He?
He's uh,
that guy is not a happy dude.
I agree.
And he likes to dominate people and he
wants to be in control and he wants to
have power.
And he got himself into a job where he
could be a get paid to be the worst kind
of murderous bully there is.
And that's what's really happening is
that we have in our society monsters and
the monsters are smart and they're
figuring out ways to get in positions of
power.
And We,
before the bloody revolution,
we just need to come up with better ways
to scan for these fucking assholes so
that we can keep them out of these
positions of power not scanned for them.
We encouraged them.
The system is built in such a way that
they're encouraged.
I mean,
it's no accident that we ended up with
psychopaths as president.
Who the fuck else would want to do that?
Who seeks a psychopath?
I don't either.
I think Obama and Jimmy Carter,
or to a real exceptions to that,
we'll wait.
Well,
we have to.
I don't think psychopath is the right
word for it,
but we do do.
You do kind of have to come up with low
maniac.
Well you need to come up with a
definition of terms,
right?
So it's like for example,
like Obama,
like you gonna have to come up with an
inarguable.
Things like Obama for sure ordered drone
strikes that killed people.
So if you order a drone strike and it
kills people,
are you a murderer or that's a question.
Are you a murderer?
If you order a drone strike and it kills
people.
And the numbers are insane.
The number of innocence is in the high
eighties.
Does that make you a murderer?
80,000
now percent.
Oh percent.
Like if you have a dentist before Jamie
with the number of innocence killed by
drone strikes,
I think it's in somewhere in the 80
range.
Eighty percent range
that that would.
Would that make him a murderer?
Like is it safe to say when you're using
adjectives for him,
you could say,
well he has.
Could you say he has murdered?
Cool.
Could you say this?
That we have an infant tile view of what
the president is because there are so
many tasks in so many human beings in so
many things that are connected to him
that the idea that he is the one giving
all the orders for all these different
things that are happening all over the
world is kind of absurd.
It's like a monotheistic God or the
Daddy.
We we really need to go to a,
a more community based understanding of
religion and politics of everything.
There shouldn't be one person in charge
of everything.
That's ridiculous.
One guy just thinking about two massive
issues,
geopolitics and a and finance.
These are two things that the government
is supposed to have their hands on,
their source to be able to control the
way we interact with world leaders,
all sorts of weird military
dictatorships and the Middle East and in
North Korea.
We have to interact with all of these
countries,
hundreds of countries.
Then on top of that,
he's responsible for job growth.
Like what?
Who is this fucking guy?
Right.
What else is he doing?
He's ordering Jones trikes.
He's ordering drone strikes to what else
is doing?
He's keeping pot illegal.
That son of a bitch,
he's appointing Supreme Court judges
just drilling in Alaska.
He's cutting a new road through the
Salmon River like he they're doing.
He's one guy,
one guy
doing any one guy with a full time job.
Doing any one of those.
Being responsible for the decisions is
crazy for any one of those things are
the public face of the world.
Do you notice a trump and I used to
think that people were exaggerating,
but he's losing his shit.
He's micro strokes.
I think he's.
He's slurring his words now a lot and he
drinks 12 cans of diet coke a day
apparently,
which made me maybe fake news.
They might be fucking with this,
I don't know,
but he watches eight hours of television
a day.
So perfect.
Representative of America.
Look at this.
Nearly 90 percent of the people killed
in air strikes were not the intended
targets during one,
five month period of operation between
January 2012 and February 2013.
Okay,
well why do they hate us?
But why do they hate?
Well,
let's talk about the psychopath.
I do eat them.
Let's talk about the psychopath idea.
Like what is a psychopath?
I mean this is a very special kind of,
of of murder that's happening here.
It's like,
you know,
okay,
let's take the classic example.
God,
Rhett,
may he rest in peace.
Charles Manson,
one of the things he always said is,
I never killed anybody.
Man.
And it's true.
I don't think he ever killed anybody.
Tex Watson did all the killings.
So in with Manson,
it's like Jesus fucking Christ.
That guy is truly.
I mean,
he really is one of the classics.
He's amazing.
He's like one of the most entertaining,
entertaining psychopaths in America.
Maybe ever.
He's really great actor.
He's a great musician,
but he's.
But the thing is like,
okay,
we know Manson.
That guy was out of his fucking Gore.
We age your garbage man.
Yeah,
yeah.
You call it garbage dump.
I call it a gold mine,
but like you take somebody like that and
it's like,
okay,
clearly nuts.
But then you take someone like Obama or
any American president who was killed so
many more people are ordered people to
kill so many more people in many of
those people or children and they're
dressed in a suit and there are dapper
and they're fucking charismatic.
I mean,
fuck.
If Obama walked into the room right now,
I do like,
wow,
Bama.
Wow,
great to meet you.
You know how you know how a drone
strikes get approved now,
lawyers,
what from the Defense Department?
Lawyers,
lawyers ultimately make the call whether
or not drone strikes get approved,
but dude,
they get together with lawyers.
That's the.
That's the day they have a target.
Say of the targets and apartment
building,
they have a Geo locator on the target,
like whatever it is,
whether it's a metadata from someone's
cell phone that indicates the cell
phones in this particular area,
how big of a target is this?
How much of a risk is it?
What's the benefits of.
And they'll,
they'll literally get together with
lawyers.
This is according to a guy that I know
that used to be one of the big wigs,
the CIA.
He's like,
this is what happens.
Mike Baker told me that.
Are they worried about getting sued or
what they're worried about the legality
of it,
how it's going to be perceived,
whether or not you can be tried as a war
criminal for this.
Ah,
yeah.
Like it's not just the scary thing is
not just that 90 are unintended targets.
It's that they know going in that
they're going to kill a bunch of
unintended gun him down.
Like you saw that collateral murder
video,
which is what put what wiki leaks on the
map when they released that video that
showed those guys gunning down and uh,
there was a minivan and these kids in
the van and let the guys literal
reaction is,
I shouldn't have brought the kids,
shouldn't have brought the kids.
We had a gun.
You down.
Oh,
whoops.
Turns out that wasn't a gun.
It was a camera.
My bad.
I mean they're gunning you down with
blurry images from the sky.
And then when,
when they killed kids or thought they'd
killed kids,
I think the kid survived.
They were like,
shouldn't have brought the kid.
Yeah.
And that.
And that's what's really wild about it,
is that freedom.
We don't yet freedom the tree of fucking
liberty.
We got to water.
What do you want the thing to weather.
But this is the,
this is that,
that to me,
this is the most interesting thing about
living in the United States is the way
that you generally don't think about
that stuff.
Like you just don't think about it.
It's not a thing that you really.
What are you going to do?
It's like,
you know,
it's happening,
we've been doing it,
you know,
we've done it over and over and over and
over and over again,
but really nobody.
What can we do?
You vote your low,
low,
be politically active and maybe you can
get somebody in power who isn't going to
kill a bunch of people,
but inevitably they keep killing a bunch
of people.
They keep doing it and we keep ignoring
it and that is one of the creepiest
fucking things because it's the,
it's like,
alright,
when here in the United States when a
cop guns down somebody,
thank God,
most people freak out.
Like that video that you tweeted.
We all look at the video.
We're like,
my God,
how did that guy get off the hook?
We used to look at his picture.
He's a monster,
but w probably today,
I don't know for sure,
but this week,
certainly this month some people got
exploded by the United States.
Right.
Does that happen?
I mean this thing about drones is they
don't really.
They don't tell you we're launching
drones
strikes and then like let's talk about
Yemen where all the weapons that Saudi
Arabia is using to starve and destroy
the Yemeni population came from the
United States,
so.
And the pilots are trained by us and so
we've got our drones blowing people up,
but also we've totally armed this
country that's destroying this other
country.
And do you know,
they know that it says USA on the bomb
fragments.
That's so fucked up.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Sorry to.
I don't,
I don't know if this will derail it,
but you know,
we're talking about Sam Harris earlier
and the Bfi have a.
it's not a beef,
but the disagreement that I have with
him around his Islam thing is that he
totally discounts the role of US foreign
policy in creating the toxic environment
that gives rise to things like isis.
So to ensure that he totally discount.
So because I don't think that's true.
Honestly,
I don't,
you know a lot more about Sam than I do,
but some of my friends and listeners
will be like,
dude,
you got to listen to convenient talking
point.
I don't think he does.
I listen to one podcast he did where he
was responding to this article in the,
the,
the publication of,
of Islamic Jihad or something,
and he was like,
look,
this is what I'm talking about.
Like all,
you know,
I'm a non Muslim,
should be killed and blah,
blah blah.
And he's going through this whole thing
and it's been a year since I listened to
it.
So you know,
apologies to Sam if I'm misremembering
this,
but what I remember thinking at the time
was he,
he said something like,
well,
there are people who think that it's US
foreign policy,
but that's ridiculous.
This is Islam.
It says it right here.
This is the ideology of Islam.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but dude,
that particular ideology of Islam is
taking hold a because of 100 years of
foreign policy of,
of humiliating and destroying these
cultures,
and B,
because of American support for the
Saudi supported a schools.
I forgot the name of the schools that
are all over the Middle East now because
of Saudi Arabia,
putting them into Pakistan and
Afghanistan and all that.
That will hobby ism.
Exactly.
Thank you.
Yeah,
so I mean I think this is really
important that when you destroy
countries and when you do it the way
we're doing it,
we don't even have the balls to go in on
the ground.
You're just blasting people from the
clouds.
It creates blowback and if that's
expressed in terms of a religious
ideology or whatever it is,
it's going to come back do.
You're absolutely right.
But there's also stuff that's happening
to places that it has nothing to do with
America.
That's also related to.
I mean look at what's going on in Iraq
when the power vacuum was created
because Saddam Hussein was killed and
the Sunni's and this year I started a
civil war and they're,
they're,
they're starting a war that has nothing
to do with America again,
and the fact that America took out their
dictator,
but why does it exist?
Who created Iraq?
We did the British and we created it and
we created it like we did.
When I say we,
I'm talking about European know post
World War II team,
US principal,
World War One.
Really?
Yeah.
Team us.
When they created these countries in
Africa as well,
they intentionally created them so that
there were opposing tribes or
populations within the country so that
they could better exercise control over
them.
Right?
So they engineered the Sunni and Shiite.
They engineered.
You look at the origins of,
and I'm not an expert,
this is.
I've read this several different places,
but I know it happened in in Africa as
well,
where they would intentionally draw the
borders so that you have different
tribes within that border who are all.
You have a long lasting and enmity with
each other so you can like arm and can
manipulate one tribe to dominate the
others.
And then when dee colonialization
happen,
then we and we have all these unstable
structures in place that we've left
behind.
I think what you're asking
lighting is that it's a very complex
issue and it's not simply just the
ideology and I 100 percent agree.
I don't think anybody who's reasonable
couldn't agree,
but I also think that there's a problem
with human psychology and ideologies and
and we have this very bizarre desire to
be all in,
in whatever team that were on and when
you're on a team that has in arguably in
2017,
the most archaic mainstream ideology
that's,
that's Islam,
right?
I mean if you stop and think about how
ancient is it in its practices the way,
especially when it's in use in radical
ways,
the way women are forced to dress the
way in Saudi Arabia,
I think up until really recently they
weren't allowed to drive.
Right now they're allowing them to
within the last two or three years,
there's a lot of like stuff in it that
we would think of as being a part of a
bygone era of human beings.
So for Alabama,
Roy Moore's losing though apparently is
he?
Yeah.
That's happening right down by 10
points.
Is paralyzed right on that.
Yeah.
There's definitely parallels.
There's,
I think it's like all things.
We're always looking for one reason why
something exists and look,
the reason why you have this idea of
jihad and jihadism being like involving
suicide bombers and sacrifice and wore a
lot of that is direct directly
attributable to what happened to
Afghanistan during the Soviet Union's
interaction with them when we were
training the Muja hi dean.
If you don't,
the way they talked people into going to
war and arm them against the Soviet
Union.
These few tile attempts.
Yeah.
There was a lot of like this.
A lot of encouragement for a lot of
these suicidal tactics.
Maybe not necessarily suicide bombing,
but the mujahideen were armed directly
by the United States and that is what
turned Osama bin Ladin against us.
Like he was with us.
Charlie Wilson's war.
You seen that movie?
No,
it's about that.
It's about the senator.
I think he was who went to Pakistan and
oversaw the arming of the Mujahideen.
Tom Hanks.
Oh,
right.
I'm the guy.
Everyone says I look like a while ago.
Philip Seymour Hoffman.
What is his name,
feel?
Seymour Hoffman and also to relate back
to what we were talking about earlier,
think about the role of sexual
frustration in getting a martyr's.
You know,
these are guys who never get laid.
A lot of them.
These kids,
man,
a buddy of mine who was over in
Afghanistan was telling me how they
would put kids in front of
because tractors weren't expensive.
Ah,
Jesus,
Dr.
Shawn,
right?
Does doesn't want that.
Dr Baker wasn't.
I was thinking that was.
I'm andy.
I'm stumped,
but no,
I think it was Sean Baker was telling me
that he was over in Afghanistan as a
medic and he was saying that these guys
had.
He's like,
I can always make another son.
I can't get another tractor.
Jesus God.
So the other kids walk in front of the
tractors to look for landmines.
D,
what does,
here's the super bowl.
The donkeys have blown up or any.
Just fucking imagine that.
That could even be something that
someone could say and you realized the
difference in the world that you'll in
the harshness of the world that you're
talking about and the worst thing.
Sorry.
The worst thing about Afghanistan is,
I mean I know a lot old hippy,
so used to that was on the hippie trail
and Afghanistan was the best place.
Everybody loved Afghanistan.
The people are so nice.
So welcoming your,
your bus breaks down in the middle of
the nowhere.
People will come from miles away from
the village and take you back to the
village and feed you and take care of
you and like it was the most hospitable
places.
I'll tell you a scary story about that
though,
because when I'm there is that one of
the teachers that he's Rom dass
retreats,
they all were on the hippie trail man.
And one of them,
her name's,
I think Mirabai Bush,
I think Mira,
Mira,
right?
Uh,
but she was telling the story how,
you know,
the hippie trail,
they get in a bus.
They traveled through Europe to end up
in India.
The fucking brotherhood of eternal love
was like just just dispensing,
just acid.
Every listing.
Do this trip.
No,
I mean you can have.
You tried fucking bringing a rainbow bus
through Afghanistan now man.
We gotta go through Iran to get the
soldiers to shoot it,
but she was telling the story about how
like all these hippies were hanging out
at.
I don't know where they were at,
but these two fucking dudes wrote up and
horses wearing like,
you know,
the,
the full garb.
They had swords in one of the hippies
said to them something like,
we're all children of God,
and he responded,
my God has no children.
It was like some kind of heavy duty is
law.
I'm just like,
fuck you hippie.
What are you talking about?
So it wasn't.
It wasn't.
It wasn't necessarily.
Everything wasn't necessarily peaceful
and joyful over there with still
fundamentalism happening there.
But I think all this shit we're talking
about,
they're really creepy thing is that
whatever this is,
whether it's the United States stuck a
fucking stick in the ants nest too much
and now we've got like these
fundamentalists lunatics who will blow
themselves up to kill other people.
Now,
whether we've got a viral form of a
religion that is infected people's
brains and is now like a contained is
going to spread with adversity.
Their real problem is we're also dealing
with an exponential increase in
technological progress and this is when
I interviewed this Guy Aaron Frank from
university and is a scary thing he said
is eventually there's going to be
technology that exists where you can
just like you can engineer a engineer
fucking ebola using some kind of
biological three d printer when,
when that,
that might be 50 years from now,
60 years from now,
I don't know,
but it's not that far away.
And also this fucking Cuban sound beam
right there.
There's kind of,
you know,
the story popped up about these people
in Cuba state.
There's some weird chirping sound.
The embassy at the embassy,
US embassy there shooting some sort of
sound weapon at them and driving them
crazy and it caused brain damage and so
when you consider that already there is
apparently some new sonic weapon
existing that can make you mentally
disabled maybe permanently.
And we're dealing with people who are
mentally disabled.
And another fucking way,
which is that they become infected with
some paradigm that makes them think that
there is an actual,
like loony God out there that wants them
to put babies in front of tractors and
that wants them to explode other people.
And they could maybe get ahold of this
sound beam that goes through walls and
just start launching it into people's
house through walls.
I think it went through a wall.
Yeah.
So they haven't defined what this weapon
is specifically,
right?
This isn't a new thing.
Well this is the.
No,
have some sound weapons,
some salad.
But this is the thing.
There was a time when a nuclear bomb did
not exist and then it existed.
There was a time when a gun didn't exist
and then it existed.
So I think it'd be a safe bet to say in
the next 50 years we're going to get
some brand new fucking weapon.
There's some guy in Darpa right now
whipping up some fucking thing.
I don't know what it is.
So who knows what it is,
you know,
just like,
uh,
a new kind of flashlight that shines
through walls.
And just makes you forget who you are,
why you saw what Elon Musk said about
the robots.
You need a strobe light to see him
because there'll be moving so fast in
two years.
Yeah.
Sleep tight,
sleep tight.
Because it's like,
you know,
not only do we have like these weapons
are in the hands right now.
Like you said,
the nuclear weapons are in the hands of
somebody won a popularity contest.
I don't know who's gonna control the
fucking robots,
but one thing's for sure,
man,
there's a lot of crazy people on the
planet right now and they're going to
have access to shit unlike anything
we've ever,
we've ever seen in the question.
Yes.
And how about a weapon that just makes
everyone.
Infant tile doesn't kill you.
Like the idea of the hydrogen bomb,
the hydrogen bomb,
right?
That kills all the people.
Leaves.
All the buildings are beautiful.
But what about neutron bomb?
Neutrons that what it is.
You're right.
What about stupid bomb?
Yeah,
like a bomb that makes everybody have a
50 Iq.
There you go.
They thought they would drop a LSD,
right?
They were experimenting with Lsd in the
sixties and seventies thinking that they
could use that to make soldiers crazy on
the battlefield,
and so he initially wanted to use
it as a truth serum.
They want to use it on captured enemy
soldiers.
Yeah.
There's.
There's some hilarious videos from the
19 fifties given soldiers acid,
world war two video.
Yeah.
We'll post World War II.
They got them all doped up on acid,
I think their English troops from the UK
and they're wandering around and black
and white footage.
Just tripping balls.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's true.
Dude.
This is the.
This is actually why we need lsd right
now because the problem is we're.
We're facing one of the most beautiful
things that could ever happen to our
society,
which is we're about to create this
beautiful technology that is going to be
something unlike anything we've ever
seen and it's wonderful.
It's wonderful.
Humans are mostly wonderful,
I think,
but we've got a few of us out there have
been infected with this thing.
You're talking about us or them,
the team attitude.
It's me and you.
It's me versus you and this is the
problem.
This is the.
This is a real problem.
How do we fix that?
That.
Because it's like,
yeah,
I don't know who caused it.
That's the thing,
like what are is fucking Harvey
Weinstein or these,
you know,
is it because we did teen teen teen boys
aren't getting jerked off enough.
I don't know.
But we do have a problem right now which
is that there's a lot of people whose
minds are scrambled with crazy ideas and
that's okay.
That's okay.
Back when there were crossbows and shit,
but now that we've got these minds
scramble with crazy ideas and access to
information about how to make fertilizer
bombs,
how to make the Ivr already heard,
ever happened.
Then with that,
what,
what did what,
where'd you get the fertilizer?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So what happened was,
so these cops,
so,
so this one cop is standing next to me
and he's like,
oh,
so you're from the states on what part
do you live in?
And we're just chatting and then this
other cop comes over and he's like,
he's like,
I'm gonna.
Press my camera.
I have to record this,
you understand that are like,
yes,
I understand you're recording me and
anything you say will be used.
Yeah,
yeah,
I understand.
And he's real up in my face and like,
I think you're lying to me and giving me
all this shit.
And then he goes away and the other
guy's like,
yeah,
don't worry.
He's like,
he gets uptight sometimes and I'm like,
oh,
so you're the good cop.
Right?
And he's like,
yeah,
yeah.
And I said,
all right,
that's fine.
As long as you're not American cop.
Right.
I'm not worried about it because I knew
like,
I knew like eventually this was going to
be just a good story.
Yeah.
And so they're like,
well,
you know,
you're bad.
Keeps coming back positive.
And they checked my hands and my,
they wiped my jeans and Shit and they
said we got to get the dog,
get the dog.
So now I'm waiting there just chatting
in the,
bring this dog.
Brian was the name of the dog and Brian
sniffed my bag and didn't.
There was nothing.
And so they were like,
eh.
Brian says,
you're,
you're good to go that crazy.
Fuck the equipment,
let's adopt a dog.
And they're telling me,
and I'm like,
guys,
there's nothing.
Trust me,
there's,
you can google me,
like I'm not,
you know,
and they're like,
the machines are never wrong.
They've literally said that.
And I'm like,
well,
they're wrong this time,
you know,
let's get 50 bucks,
50 pounds,
you know,
and like,
yeah,
we don't bet.
Anyway,
so finally I was like,
when the,
when the dog was like,
you know,
that I was free,
I say,
can I do a group Selfie with you guys?
Like put it on Instagram,
that'd be pretty funny.
And they're like,
Nah,
we can't ever faces on right.
But you can take a picture with Brian.
So I got picture with the dog licking my
cheek and Heathrow,
hilarious.
Bought a laptop once,
red band and uh,
he was selling this windows laptop.
I want it to get a second laptop.
And the first time I used it took it
through the airport and uh,
it got screened.
So,
uh,
they pull you aside.
We're going to have to check this again.
Have you been near farm?
No,
I didn't know what that meant back then.
I didn't know about the fertilizer.
They checked my hands.
Nothing.
They swab the entire laptop and they'll
test positive for fertilizer and cum
stains.
It's probably just red bands.
Just fucking a computer.
But they,
they went over it with a fine tooth comb
with a swab and they went up and down.
They had asked me a bunch of questions
and I'll explain what I do.
I'm a comedian,
you know,
a host fear factor.
And they go,
oh,
okay.
All right.
Get outta here.
Just gave it to me.
Gave me the laptop.
Because they recognized you?
Yeah,
because they checked the laptop.
They,
I said I bought it from a friend.
This is the work around the farm.
I go,
I don't think so.
And uh,
they just tested it and they swapped it
and whatever the minimal amount of
nitrogen or that they found on it,
which exists in fertilizer,
but also in bombs somehow or another.
But it's also,
by the way,
nitrogen is the most common thing in the
air.
The air's 80 percent nitrogen.
How they're getting.
What they're getting off of the laptop,
I don't know why it would test positive
or what have you,
but it was apparently a minimal amount
in some way,
shape or form.
They thought it was okay.
I thought they were going to turn it on
and check the content and you're going
to get in trouble for
writing all the shit that I write down
like the fuck is wrong with your head,
but like if you worked on a farm and you
got that nitrogen shit all over,
you feel like you were laying down some
fertilizer and gotten your clothes and
you went straight to the airport.
You're not flying anywhere,
bro.
Yeah.
They check you and they find that shit
on you.
You know,
if there's somehow or another it gets
detected.
It's touching your bags or something
like that.
Like you're gonna you're going to be in
for some questioning.
You know?
That sucks man.
So what do you think's gonna happen with
this democratization of weaponry that
you were talking about?
Because sometimes I think he could be a
good thing if everybody had the capacity
to destroy the planet.
No Way.
It's not a good thing.
It's like,
well,
that's where we're going,
where we're going to have to kill the
people that we think would possibly
destroy
on it,
and then everyone's going to be scared.
It's going to be like mccarthyism for
nuclear catastrophe.
Everyone's
going to think that metro our
destruction,
which works when one of the,
when both people are saying,
but when you're dealing with someone who
wants to die and like and like these
shooters,
when you look at what's happening with
these shooters,
like the guy in Vegas,
that's an example of a lunatic,
getting ahold of some technology and
using that technology to wipe out a shit
ton of people not caring if he's going
to die.
What if that guy was up there with a
fucking Cuban sonic,
dumdum beam just blasting people with
this beam that's making them for the
rest of their lives,
have some kind of neurological
impairment.
What if that person,
God forbid he was up there like dusting
out smallpox that he printed up and his
three d printer.
It's like the creepy thing about it is
Chris,
that there is not a solution.
I don't even know how you,
like we're looking at like huge chunks
of the human population that believe
that in this insane creator force that
actually wants them to explode
themselves.
You know,
they went in and like that,
that shooting that just happened where
the isis came in and just fucking
executed a bunch of Sufi.
He's,
you know,
and Egypt and Sufi Islam.
Like that's,
that's,
you know,
it's such a,
it's like mystical Islam.
It's beautiful.
It's beautiful dancing.
Yes.
It's dancing and so,
so we already have this kind of insanity
bubbling up in different parts of the
planet.
So in that,
and then you have white,
the loner person who just for whatever
reason decides to go and shoot up a
church or whatever.
This is all like Sam Harris arguments.
This is Sam Harris believes in when it
comes to like ideologies being
incredibly toxic in that form.
Yeah.
They can be,
they can be.
Yeah.
They can be.
I want to start a fight with Sam Harris,
but I like him.
It seems like a fun thing to do.
I'm going to get you a few of your.
Hey Mr.
logical focus,
I'll get you for your focus being right
all the time.
No,
no,
but,
but the um,
the.
Yeah man,
this is like a,
this is ai is a big problem,
but also the fact that the current ai
that we're running,
the human operating system is like
already fucking up in this kind of
intense way.
It's,
it's.
I don't know what the solution is.
No one can really even think about it,
but it's,
it is going.
It's a problem in the most intense way.
Well,
here's how easy the ais to hack Donald
Trump who's never been religious at any
point in his life ever now is able to
say,
God bless America and everybody starts
clapping and they believe that he
believes that God is blessing of
America,
which has never been a part of his
thought process.
Right?
That's right.
Like there's a giant history of Donald
Trump interacting with the world.
Never were.
Was there any proselytizing,
right?
There's never any espousing or have any
religious doctrines
are talking about the greatness of
Christianity.
But now he does it and because he's in
this position where you have to believe
it.
We accept that new variation in his
speech,
the now he brings God into the equation.
We never brought God into the equation
before.
That's so creepy,
man.
The way you just said,
I didn't know what you're talking about
because I'm like,
trump definitely didn't hack any fucking
ai,
but now I hear what you're saying.
Yeah,
yeah.
He's,
he's tapped into this human ai acquire
their requirement to believe in
supernatural beings that are looking out
for us.
That's a requirement in 2017.
You cannot.
Like if Chris Ryan wanted to run for
president,
one of the real issues,
it would be as I can't trust an atheist.
Right?
Oh,
I think that's gonna be the least.
I just read your book.
We got to sit down and talk is I'm not
some crazy polygamous monkey person.
Be My first press conference would be a
doozy.
Let me tell you.
You're great.
Yeah,
man.
That's that.
So that,
that is the problem is the human ai.
We're getting better at hacking it.
You know that.
This is.
I don't think it was St Harris who said
it though.
It might've been.
Maybe it was Elon Musk,
he was saying everyone thinks the
problem with a,
with ai is that it's going to be robots
killing people,
which is one part of it,
but the real problem is that the ai is
going to be able to start hacking the
human operating system and we kind of
have already witnessed that with the
twitter bots.
So it's like you can produce the uh,
uh,
you can produce the illusion of a
majority opinion using bots.
So,
and the more advanced right now you can
usually,
you can at least kind of tell what the
bots are like.
You go back and look and you realize the
body has been tweeting every like five
minutes and it's got like lists of
people in it and it's usually tweeting
memes and it seems to be
Ben have,
you'd have to chase it down if you just
looked at the comments itself after a
post,
like say if you're someone who opposes
president trump and they've got trump
bots that they use to go and attack
someone who says anything bad about
trump,
you would just see the overwhelming
negative response versus positive.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
but you could still,
I guess what I'm saying is like right
now there's a way you can tell
something's a bot,
but as ai gets better,
you're going to start seeing.
I've been thinking about this.
You're going to start seeing these
basically social networking farmers.
So the idea's like I created a teenage
bought in.
I figured out a way to get it to create
its own facebook account and for like,
I don't know,
six years,
it just posts shit on its own facebook
account.
Giving the illusion that this is a
living thing.
Now if I could do that with 7,000
of these teen bots,
so now I have a,
have a bought swarm of 7,000
ais that all have facebook accounts,
twitter accounts,
instagram accounts that they've been
somehow populating with bullshit content
for like seven years.
So now no one can really even tell if
it's a person or not.
I've got a really
super powerful weapon and so I think
that's what's the real creepy thing with
ai is.
And,
and you know,
you've seen that shit that popped up on
the Internet.
The ability.
Here's a road in the day.
Look,
we just made it look like it's winter
now.
We just made it look like it's nighttime
We just made it look like it's whatever,
anytime of year that we want we can
make.
It's going to get to the point where we
can make a person look like they said
anything and you're not going to be able
to tell the difference.
And then on top of that,
that's here.
By the way,
I think it was radio lab or something
that did a podcast here.
It's close.
It's discernible,
but it's getting close.
So.
So we're talking about reality video and
audio.
Yeah,
it it.
It's reality bombs where you're going to
be able to bomb a culture with ai
produced the illusion of anything that
you fucking want,
whatever you want,
but in dme and people are gonna,
believe it,
but devil's advocate here.
Haven't we been doing that for a long
time?
Isn't that what a laugh track is?
A studio audience,
but it's creating the illusion of
community of a bunch of people that
believe a certain thing that react
certain ways and that manipulates the
hordes.
Bernays wrote about this in the twenties
about manipulating and effective.
It's already been in its rudimentary
form.
Now imagine a super advanced form of
that and what you're looking at is like
the re one of the real problems of ai
that maybe is more problematic than
robots going so fast.
You have to use a strobe light to see
them.
We're talking about people no longer if
you believe that anything in the media
or on the Internet is real or if you've
been trying to like establish your
concept of what the universe is or the
world is based on the news based on the
Internet and people have been doing that
for a long time with newspapers and
shit.
Then we're going to enter into a phase
in human history where that is no longer
necessarily a way for us to gauge what
reality actually is because we're not
even gonna know fucking humans are
creating the content.
We're not going to get to a certain
point in time where we're not going to
know if someone's human.
Yeah,
blade is a real thing that's going to
happen.
Yeah.
That's not far away.
They have some pretty God damn
convincing robot heads now in Japan.
Sex robots looking pretty good.
They don't look too bad and we're.
We're getting real close.
We're getting within 50 years away from
an indiscernible artificial life form.
Buddy of mine had a wet dream recently.
He's in his forties and he had a wet
dream where he was having sex with two
revolutions.
Sex robots.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And that chicken,
even though you could see right through
her legs,
she was clear.
She had clear arms and shit.
You still fuck shit up.
Beautiful.
She was nice to you.
How do you know what is real?
I mean,
if it interacts with you,
if you're talking to a premier shit,
here's where it gets really interesting
is like there's this mystic name
Gurdjieff,
and he called people spiritual
machines and so his thing was like most
people already are.
Robots are automatons and the sense that
most people when they're doing anything,
whatever the thing is they're doing,
it's imitation.
So when a person like you know,
does any,
the way a person,
a person who's acting cool,
right?
Usually the person who is acting cool
has Emma is learned that from something.
It's all limitation.
It's all autopilot already.
So most human beings,
they're not even autonomous at all.
Like how most of it,
most people will spend like three
fucking days completely up in their
heads.
Not even knowing where they're at.
I mean,
I know I've been in that situation where
like sometime will pass and suddenly
I'll be like,
wait,
what the fuck?
I've been in my head for three days
straight.
I'm running on autopilot.
What's going on here man?
That's like,
how many people are.
They wake up in the morning,
they get their coffee to get in a car.
They go and do their thing.
They come back,
they go to bed.
They barely even know what they're
doing.
Momentum,
momentum.
Right?
So,
so we're already dealing with a kind of
organic robot,
a meat machine that's barely even aware
of what it's doing,
you know,
which is why I think,
and I know you and I talk about Christ a
lot,
I'm going to bring it up on your show.
Again.
When Jesus is being crucified,
I think one of the most poignant things
and the new testament is when Jesus is
being crucified,
he looks out and he says,
father,
forgive them.
They know not what they do.
And a lot of people interpret that as
being like they don't know I'm Jesus,
but I think what he's really saying is
they don't know what they're fucking
doing,
man,
period.
Period.
They're just on autopilot.
They don't know what they're not.
They're barely sentience yet.
Termites in the mountain.
Now let's think about what we were
talking about earlier when we're talking
about a 50 year old who's trying to grab
it.
No,
no,
I didn't know if you were passing it.
Give them some of that shit.
When we're talking about 50 year olds or
50 year old movies,
you know those old movies where men
smacked women and grabbed them and and
how you're seeing these big changes in
the way people behave.
Now let's go 2000 years ago.
Let's,
let's,
let's go way back before written things
right,
and let's go back before anybody knew
how to write things down or read and
let's imagine
like what is that?
Ten thousand years ago,
crypt 15,
that was eight for writing rudimentary
writing.
It's all.
It's all insane.
If you really think about the amount of
raw change that's happening in our life,
just what's going on right now with this
whole me too.
Movement,
the sexual harassment and sexual
assault,
an outing of all these predators,
all of this stuff.
I'm good.
Just put all this stuff that's happening
now,
is this,
they get accelerated evolution,
accelerated cultural compatibility like
accelerated understanding of it.
Almost like a,
a new,
a new version of equality because it
used to be that like you could fuck your
employee because your employee couldn't
say anything.
Right?
Right.
They couldn't do anything.
Well,
now they can.
Now everybody can and now other people
find out about you and now it becomes an
issue.
It's all forced and so now we're going
to change the way we think about
behaving now and our standards going to
change because our standards have
radically changed from a thousand years
ago.
Radically changed from 2000 years ago
and radically changed from the 19
fifties.
If you look at the 19 fifties and we see
it in uniquely,
so in the 19 fifties is that we can see
it in the form of mainstream media
films.
You can read about it in books,
but seeing it visually in films,
it's so shocking and stunning and you
see just the way people interacted with
each other and you just think about if
someone from like 1950 tried to exist
today,
it would be hilarious.
Would be hilarious.
Just watching them try to interact with
everybody with phones and all the
studies.
They literally would be like a person
from a foreign world that's going to be
us a hundred years from now.
One hundred years from now this world
will be indiscernible.
It's going.
The technology is like literally a
yellowstone about to blow up the entire
country that literally about the super
volcano,
the whole world,
and no one is prepared for the
consequences.
We just assume that the paradigms that
exist today are going to remain and that
it's just going to get better.
It'd be easier to text people.
No,
no,
no.
This,
this paradigm did not exist 2000 years
ago.
This world,
the world,
the way we operate and communicate and
even get around.
How about the way we get around?
How about this hard surface and these
metal boxes of rubber tires and now
fucking drive themselves.
I mean we.
We're at the.
We're at,
we're in the middle of it,
but we're also at the gate to like
insanity,
pure,
absolute world changing and sandy from
DNA with Crispr,
they've just started injecting it into
live people.
Now,
some guy with some incurable disease
allowed them to Guinea pig on him.
What if he gets fucking cured?
Right?
What if people figure out a way to get
smarter?
What have they developed?
Crispr telekinesis modules where they
can insert them into your fucking head
and use it,
works off your own body's electricity
and they never run bad and we all talk
to each other through our minds and then
in school they have to teach kids a new
language,
a universal language that's not not
phonetically based,
so people stopped talking.
So our heads grow big.
Like aliens are.
Miles shiver up just like the aliens.
That's what the aliens.
That's what that.
That archetype is.
That alien archetype is like what we
know we're going to look like.
If we keep going,
we're all going to be like a merge of
colors because that's problematic.
All that Dick Stuff.
That shit just gets in the way.
Dude.
Your your database now on your brain.
Sure.
Well,
I liked this is the way Mckenna talked
about how like what he say octupus like
that.
Like all the limbs,
like they build the.
It has to communicate with body language
is so much more profound than it's like.
Yeah.
Not only are we not going to have this
form,
we're going to be able to decide any
form we want,
any form,
anything you want to be,
want to be a fucking octupus.
Theoretically you could be an optimist
if we get.
If we get to that point,
if we get to that point also nuclear
arsenals,
nuking ourselves or without like actual
yellowstone or without like sending out.
Maybe we just haven't produced,
you know,
we're,
we always are scanning this guys for
radio signals or that's what we used to
do,
but maybe we haven't even produced a
signal than an advanced civilization
would identify as being something that
would come from a civilization.
And the moment we do it,
the moment somebody at cern or somebody
at Darpa produces some kind of beam that
emanates from the planet.
It just summons a,
just a fucking legion of like crafts
that just want to enslave us,
you know?
You know what I mean?
It just like the first little like boop,
and then they're ready to harvest them.
Weirdest thoughts that I've ever had
about interacting with other aliens or
other life forms for another planet is
not that it's a signal,
it's not that like you you'd like,
but you can go to a place that you can
transform,
like whatever your consciousness is into
something that can travel to different
dementias and that these things exist in
dimensional planes as much as they exist
in physical locations,
so maybe it's got a physical location of
a hundred billion light years away or
whatever the fuck it is.
Right?
Yeah,
but it's also right here.
like in that it's all tied in together.
Like there's this really rudimentary
crude physical distance space that we
operate in on a daily basis because
we're still as advanced as we are for
earth.
We're still fairly low level in terms of
the ability to spring forth and entire
universe from something the size of the
head of a pin,
which is what the Big Bang is,
right?
So some insanely complex webbing of just
insane distance plus potential life
forms and different styles of,
of,
of life that could exist and all these
different planets.
Hundreds of billions of known galaxies
in the universe.
It's so big.
Lawrence Krauss tried to explain to me
the size of the universe and he changed
the way I looked at it because he said
it's not that we know for sure that the
universe is 13 point 7 billion years
old,
but that's as far back as we can see
with what we have now.
And he was saying that time that he was
trying to make some distinction between
the amount of time it would take to go
back more than 13 point 7 billion years
in that time literally moves faster than
that and that you can't detect it after
what we're not.
We're,
we're very limited in our ability to
detect things after a certain space.
So he's not necessarily.
The Universe is only 13 point 7 billion
years old.
It might be infinitely old.
It's like that's as far as we can see
what their.
So we assume
that's all there is.
Well that's what they have to operate
on.
What they can prove now.
Right?
So this is what they're saying.
What we can prove now is that light is
the light.
We're getting is 13 point 7 billion
years old or the radio waves that
indicate that there was some sort of an
explosion,
but all of it is like super sketchy man.
They're writing things down on a little
legal notepad.
They're all agreeing with the math and
looking at it and they're way fucking
smarter than me,
so they're probably right about a lot of
stuff,
but it's entirely possible that just we
don't have the ability to detect how
much further it actually goes back.
Might have this whole faulty assumption
of this initial beginning of the
universe might be bullshit.
There might literally not have ever been
a beginning because it has always been
here.
Right?
Well,
in my area they've been saying
anatomically modern human beings have
existed for 200,000
years.
That's what everybody,
including me,
rights in the books,
you know the accepted wisdom couple
months ago they found remains in
Morocco.
That seemed to be about 300,000
years old that appear to be from
anatomically modern human.
So it's like,
oh,
well.
So when you say something goes back
while you've had Graham Hancock on a
lot,
right,
where you say something goes back a
certain amount of time,
often what you're saying is that's how
far back we.
We found something for that.
We can detect it in the case of the
space exploration.
Insane.
And here's what's really insane.
Let's give him the benefit of the doubt.
Let's go half a million.
That's not.
Yeah,
it's a blink of an eye.
A half a million years ago.
We were literally some kind of eighth
thing half a million years ago,
right?
Yeah.
Well we,
Australia pithy,
that gets 2 million years ago.
Australopithecus,
you know,
I stick with anatomically modern humans,
which is why that really jumps out at
me.
But yeah,
I'm not real clear on Australia,
Perth,
the kiss and Cro Magnon.
And uh,
I know neanderthals lived up to about
40,000
years ago.
Can interbred with human.
How crazy is that one?
Yeah.
So that means there was some sort of
like cultures,
there was some sort of like villages and
shit back then.
Now stop and think how crazy that is.
And we're,
we're,
we're talking about like Mesopotamia or
mayor or a rack,
we're talking about these incredibly
advanced for the time civilizations that
are like the oldest known modern style
civilizations,
early 6,000
years old.
I know.
It's crazy.
It's so crazy.
And the other thing,
I actually had an idea for a book which
the rate I write,
I'll never live to write it,
but the idea is to look at the known
unknowns in science,
right?
Because there are things that are you
elucidated and example earlier where
it's like,
look,
that's how far we can detect that
doesn't mean that's how far it is.
So we know,
we don't know that
there's a lot of arrogance in the
assumption that we have all the data
when it comes to the civilizations to
like how old they are.
Like who you're,
you're weird going into 6,000
years,
you're not getting a lot of stuff when
you go for thousand years before that
you're getting way less stuff.
You go 4,000
years before that.
You might not have any stuff left.
Right?
Right.
There might be like some shards of metal
that you can explain and you can carbon
date those anyway.
Right.
And I think rock you can carbon date.
You need like physical things later,
like living right,
like you need like wood or food for
carbon,
carbon dating.
Is that how they're doing it still?
No,
I think there's a,
there's some other,
uh,
isotope that they're using that they
don't need the carbon,
the carbon is accepted and the other
one's quite new.
It's pretty fucking crazy.
They were so smart,
not us obviously,
but someone out there is so smart.
They could take a piece of something and
tell you roughly how old it is.
That's fucking nuts.
And apparently gets a little screwy in
places where there's higher levels of
carbon and there's like some weirdness
to it,
especially initially when it was first
invented,
but just the fact that that exists,
that someone could say,
oh,
well we found out that the dinosaurs
died 65 million years ago.
You're like,
what the fuck?
Do you know that Chesney fuck?
Did you figure that out?
And and meanwhile,
probably a hundred years from now,
they'll have something that'll tell you
that day the asteroid hit,
they'll,
they'll show you like a model of the
Yucatan before and after.
You'll be able to watch it with the HTC
Vive,
put it over your head.
You'll be able to literally watch an
accurate representation of that giant.
Was it five miles wide?
Yeah.
The crater.
The action asteroid itself that killed
all the dinosaurs.
Yeah.
I want to say it was five miles wide,
but it might be making that up.
Five.
Imagine five mile wide city slamming
into the earth,
going 45,000
miles an hour from space and you could
watch it all take place in virtual
reality.
That's going to happen.
You gotta be able to see it.
You're going to literally witness the
people coming off the mayflower and
clubbing native Americans and raping
them and killing them.
You will be able to literally see
westworld.
You Seen Westworld?
Yeah.
It's intense,
but I mean,
I think that they're going to be able to
recreate things in.
As computing power gets more and more
power.
The only real problem would be things
that really prehistorical in terms of
like cultural things,
maybe not like physical animal things,
but as far as like things that people
did or didn't do because they vary so
much,
it'd be so hard to pin down without real
accurate like images and videos,
but from here on out,
from here on out there,
they're going to be able to have
recreations of things that happened that
are going to be indistinguishable.
They have images of all of us.
Everybody has a facebook page.
Everybody has a picture of you.
Alright,
so the 300 billion,
whatever it will be in 100 years,
320 million people that exist in this
country right now.
There's a probably a picture of
everybody that that was not the case a
hundred years ago.
Right?
In the future,
there's going to be some sort of a three
dimensional version of you that you use
as an Avatar and you three d games and
that's going to look exactly like you
and they're going to be able to make
something that literally recreates
moments in your life.
Well,
they're gonna.
Be able to like take your social
thumbprint.
They're going to be able to
theoretically they could scan all your
instagram posts or facebook posts,
all your tweets,
even your podcast,
analyze your voice,
get an idea of your personality,
construct some kind of massive amount of
data,
feed it to an ai,
say create a personality based on this
person,
here's their picture,
animate the picture and now you've
cloned yourself in ai is like basically
imbued all the data that exists and has
been used to imbue an image of you with
your personality and now you are living
in some kind of simulator,
which means that you're going to be able
to anyone who has ever had their picture
taken and as some kind of data out there
to establish some kind of personality.
You're gonna.
Be able to use that to make a.
to simulate individuals that have lived
in the past and do it.
It's going to get really interesting
ethically because it's like,
all right,
let me fucking take.
Like,
I dunno,
he's somebody out there with like a huge
social.
Like,
let me take Taylor swift.
Right?
I'm going to take her.
I'm gonna have my ai produce a mini
Taylor swift and I'm going to drop her
into like a simulated reality filled
with fire breathing scorpions to see
what Taylor swift would do if she was
like running through some doom
simulator.
They're gonna have to come up with laws
about this,
which is like you don't,
you can't duplicate,
you can't duplicate without permission.
You know,
talked about them on the podcast before
with robots.
We were like,
what's going to stop you from making a
replica of say Jennifer Lopez for a sex
robot?
It looks exactly like Jennifer Lopez and
is that a violation of her?
You go over,
you know,
you go to the store and you could
literally buy a Jennifer Lopez fucked
all.
It looks indistinguishable.
You take it home and you fucked Jennifer
Lowe more like,
more than likely it's going to be.
You're going to have some kind of like
what you would have,
I guess would be some kind of generic
looking fucked all,
but you put ai goggles on or augmented
reality goggles on it projects,
whoever you want onto this thing.
So it's like you don't have,
you don't,
you wouldn't go buy a fucked all based
on a celebrity.
You would just have some kind of like
basically a screen in the form of an
android that your augmented reality
would project a person onto that.
So it kind of in love.
Yeah.
Well I mean that's the,
that's where it gets a deal person on
doesn't want.
And that's where it gets really fucking
weird is that's the other thing that
you're going to be able to do is you're
gonna be able to sit across from someone
and project onto them.
Anyone that you want so that no longer
you know,
you'll,
you'll be talking to western Winston
Churchill,
your girlfriend.
Exactly.
You and I could,
could cope project something onto Joe.
Could be like a game we'd play together.
Yeah.
Well especially if we all decided to
live in virtual reality and if we spent
most of our time alone in a room,
but we felt like we were all hanging out
together and the feeling is
indistinguishable than being in a
physical location.
Right.
This is going to be a lot of that going
on,
man.
Then you don't need a body anymore.
We're going to get super close to the
alien thing,
man.
We're going to engineer big giant heads
and we're all going to exist in there.
There's going to be htc vives built was
no more atmosphere.
We're going to blow out the atmosphere.
So we have built in sunglasses.
That's why the aliens have the big black
eyes.
Those are like bill built in ray band.
Wayfair's.
Yeah,
dude,
I think it's brought to you by ray ban
skin that doesn't get cancer.
It's bulletproof to figure that out.
Don't you think this is like when you,
when you smoked DMT and I've never
smoked dmt and I never would do any
illegal psychedelic,
but let's say that I had,
let's say that I had recently done it at
like,
I don't know,
burning man where no one's doing drugs
there anymore,
but let's say that I had done it there,
but I,
they're so confused anymore.
Back in the old days,
it was like,
so making up that I had had that I had a
crazy
man where,
uh,
I looked down after drinking this very
strong mint tea and I saw this,
I saw this fucking,
I don't know,
it looked like a,
it was a look,
kind of like a cow or something,
but coming out of it,
it had this long neck with like a
technological lantern hanging off of it.
And I'm looking at that thing.
And what's interesting about dmts,
you look away and he looked back now
fucking things still there,
man.
It's just right there.
I'm like,
what the fuck got sucked through this
tube into this beautiful,
beautiful domed structure.
Oh Man.
It was so pretty and it was just
spinning with potential.
It's just pure potentiality and I'm
looking at this incredible thing.
It's technology for sure.
I mean,
whatever.
This was the way my brain was
interpreting it as like,
this is technology.
Like I'm looking at some kind of super
advanced simulator or some kind of
machine that is like simulating
realities and I'm looking at it.
It's like,
my God,
it's just so much potential here,
but I thought to myself,
I'm going to miss my friends if I have
to hang out in this place,
because the interesting thing about dmt
is that there's a sense of,
or I've heard other people report this,
a sense of incredible familiarity or
you're like,
I have been here.
In fact this is home,
and then you realize that feeling of
coming home is actually this is that
it's not even close to the feeling of
being at home here and I'm looking
around at this and thinking,
yeah,
but my friends,
my friends,
what about all my friends?
I'm going to,
I'm in this space,
I'm going to miss them,
and that thing,
it doesn't talk to you,
but it's like,
might as well be a voice is like,
oh,
you can always go back there and then I
open my eyes and I'm back at burning
man,
hanging out with my friends and that's
when I realized,
Oh fuck,
I get reincarnation,
man.
I get it.
This thing you're talking about the
simulator that is going to happen
sometimes after having taken
psychedelics.
You think,
no,
it's already fucking happened and this
thing that we're in right now are alive.
The idea of reincarnation is you die and
then you become a goat or something
crazy like that larva slug,
but what if it's that you die.
You pop into that dmt realm and you get
to jump back into your life at any frame
of your life that you want to.
You can.
You can actually repopulate your life or
reincarnate your life at any moment.
So you die.
You become the universal
superintelligence and then you gaze back
into what happened,
and usually it's like in Buddhism they
say the cause of suffering is
attachment.
That that what you're attached to that
life,
this thing you just were this fucking
interdimensional temporal worm that
burrowed through time with every action
that you took and you're like,
yeah,
well you're just.
You.
You're like,
I want to go back.
I want to go back to this moment right
now,
and I was podcasts when my pals doing a
shrimp parade and then boom,
there you are.
You're back back in your life.
So in any given moment,
you could be reincarnating a million
fucking times.
You could just be like always coming
back to any frame of your life that you
want.
And anyway,
this is what came to me out there in the
desert.
And I was thinking,
oh,
I get it.
It's not like you reincarnate into other
life forms.
You keep repeating your life,
but it's not a circle.
It's a spiral hopefully,
because each time you can improve a
little bit more,
you can improve a little bit more,
make decisions that you normally
wouldn't make.
Which is why,
like at any given moment,
you know the big moments that come when
you're around somebody and you're about
to say some shitty fucking thing to,
um,
you know,
your enemy,
your whoever it may be that moment where
you're like about to do the fucking
thing you always do.
And you can feel it like you're.
You feel this gravitational pull to the
habituation.
And in that moment you're like,
you don't say the shitty thing.
And that moment you discipline yourself,
you control yourself.
You don't do the thing.
You've always done whatever it is.
And in that moment,
your life spirals up a little bit and
now you're existing in like a completely
new new,
like essentially a new universe plan.
What you hit a higher place.
Exactly.
That's kind of in a way that replicates
what you talk about sometimes on your
social media.
I see on your instagram,
like taming the inner bitch you have the
thing.
The other day he was like,
you know,
I really do not want to do this today.
You know,
you got up,
you know,
after you do the show the night before,
whatever.
And you did it.
And at the end of it,
by doing that thing you didn't want to
do or not doing the thing you do want to
do.
Conversely you do move to a higher level
and feel way better use.
And,
and that.
So that thing,
that thing you,
you,
you instagrammed,
um,
which I think is super cool thing that
you do because I think it's like,
a lot of people need to like think,
yeah man,
I could fucking.
Anytime I want.
I could just start jogging and.
But it's like you could like really,
you could,
you just start doing it.
You don't even have to be good at it.
You don't have to do anything.
Could just make sure,
make sure you do it.
If you just do that,
everything changes for the better.
And that seems easy.
It
seems so ridiculous.
But you need to hear people say it and
you need to hear someone say it.
Who actually does it?
Yes.
Now that you know Rupert Sheldrake,
I think you might have had them on.
Oh,
cool.
Okay.
So you know his idea of the Ronnell and
the timespace content,
he calls it a runnel basically.
So that feeling when you're like,
fuck,
I'm not going to have a writing.
You're not just feeling your own,
like,
you know,
lack of ambition or laziness.
You're literally feeling.
Now again,
I don't believe it's just like a thought
experiment or whatever,
but you're literally feeling the
gravitational pull of infinite lifetimes
where in that moment you decided not to
go running.
You're actually feeling like the track
that you've carved deep into the time
space continuum by every time that
moment appears you keep making,
so when you actually do go,
I'm going to go fucking running your
kind of climbing out of this trench that
you've dug into time over countless
incarnations and when you do that and
you're out there running,
you're like in a new dimension.
Now you're like,
what the fuck?
This is the dimension where I decided to
go running and then that and that's why
everything starts changing a little bit.
When you make these decisions,
big life changing moves.
Those are good for you and for some
people going out.
Jogging can be a life changing move.
It doesn't have to be some spectacular
thing.
It can be as simple as
taking a yoga class,
deciding to take a yoga class twice a
week or three times a week and change
your life.
Calling someone who you've said some
shitty thing too because they're.
They did something wrong and a Po and
being the bigger person apologizing
instead of holding that stupid garage,
calling them up and being like,
Hey,
I'm sorry.
I was fucking mad.
I love you.
You're great.
Instead of like carrying on with this
stupid angry war carousel and the
carousel.
Anytime you make decisions like that,
things get better so fast and then like,
I don't know if you've noticed that
there's,
I've noticed like synchronicities start
happening more like good luck starts
happening.
More like interesting things start
Yeah,
I think you,
we,
we fight against ourselves sometimes
accidentally liked me when I was young.
When I was young I would have an
interaction with someone and then I
would always imagine what they were
going to say when we talked again and
then I would imagine me talking shit to
them and that I would imagine then
getting upset at me and having a
delusional perspective.
I would like play out this weird play in
my mind.
I'm on.
And then when I was in my twenties I
started to realize how preposterous it
was.
Took me that long and I realized like
I'm wasting all this time and I didn't
realize it was crazy.
I didn't realize other people did.
I talked to my friend Brian once and he
was saying the same thing.
I go,
you have arguments with people that
aren't there.
It goes all the fucking time,
all the fucking time.
I have arguments in my head with people
that were there that's like sometimes
you'll have a conversation with someone
about something and then you both
immediately are like relieved and start
laughing because you were both expecting
the other person to be like Super Mad
and come in like an asshole,
but meanwhile you're both
apologize and then it just goes away and
then everybody feels way better.
A better way.
Better like conflict is stupid.
What's not stupid is exercising out all
the anxiety that your body possesses,
that it creates conflict in the first
place.
Whether it's exercising it through
meditation or through taking a yoga
class or doing something physical.
That just gives you some relief of
stress because you exert yourself.
It doesn't have to be anything crazy.
Fucking going on a nice hike.
You go on a nice hike,
you get to see things and you feel
better like you're walking.
The blood starts pumping through your
brain.
You come up with great ideas when you
hike,
you know,
it's like all these things are just
little incremental steps at every one of
us can take and you do that and it
changes everything.
Then you be nicer,
nicer to people.
That changes everything too.
And it helps you to be nicer if you have
control of your physical body.
That's it.
And,
and the,
you know,
the question that we're talking about
earlier,
it's like,
what the fuck do we do about the
lunatics out there?
Well,
what you do,
man,
you,
I mean,
if you can,
you start with a fucking lunatic that
you're sitting in right now.
That's what you do.
Absolutely.
Lunatic.
And then,
and then,
and,
and that,
I mean,
that's,
that's exactly what Rom da says is,
uh,
we work on ourselves so we can help the
people next to us.
And that's all you can do because you
can't do shit,
man,
to make another person.
You're not really gonna do much to the
other people around you.
They're going to do their own thing.
They're going to decide.
I mean,
this is something I've been thinking
fucking Jesus,
because a lot of people talk about
miracles and stuff,
especially like in the camps I hang out
with.
Like Duncan says,
I've been thinking about fucking Jesus.
No,
I will.
That's freaking.
That's a different thing.
Fucking fucking Jesus.
Yeah,
I would totally do it.
It's a different thing that you've
already done it.
If you do DMT,
I,
but that's part of the experience.
Making Christ,
having intercourse with the Christ.
It would be an honor through all pours.
It would be an honor.
You go together like you just merge.
You just merged.
You just merge.
You're on your knees again at the video
store.
This guy,
it's always dirty with him,
but she never be just psychedelic,
psychedelic love about Jesus.
Just be on your knees choking on Christ.
Come or not,
but I can guarantee you can guarantee
that's going to be a semi.
A sex simulator for sure.
My to Christ there.
Sure,
sure.
Of the Virgin Mary.
She was hot.
These people,
they talk about mirrors.
Nice guys.
Come on.
I'm trying to talk about fucking
miracles here.
So I know these people,
they talk about miracles that bunch and
like,
you know,
having seen some of these fucking gurus
do crazy shit,
but they always say it doesn't matter.
Like ultimately these are dishes like
fireworks,
kind of.
It's just like tricks.
It's a firework.
It doesn't because like the thing is
like you could sit in front of someone
and like levitate bottles in front of
him,
like levitate a bunch of bottles,
teleport across the room,
come back and then tell the person,
you know,
you're going to be a lot happier if you
go jogging.
Like someone could do that to me and
tomorrow I'm gonna wake up.
And I was like,
yeah,
he levitated bottles.
He poured across the room.
They told me I should go jogging,
I'll probably go tomorrow.
No fucking jogging.
I don't care.
They don't care the liver.
So the,
you know what I mean?
It doesn't matter.
None of it.
None of the point is like if.
So if a person who can levitate bottles
probably isn't gonna,
make you go jogging,
then certainly you're not going to be
able to talk to a person and be like,
hey,
you know you're going to feel better if
you do this,
you all you can really do is look at
yourself and be like,
you know what,
I'm gonna go fucking jogging.
This is a really good point.
What is,
what's your take on this in terms of
like the miracles in the Bible?
Like some of the weirder ones like
walking on water,
like what do you do?
What do you think that's about?
What do you think like the.
Even though the interpretation of those
is kind of suspect,
right?
Like what isn't the walking on water is
a weird one because I think it has to do
with translation and I think that it
could be interpreted in other languages
walking by the water,
like walking near the water could be
thought of as levitating and walking on
water polo and the preposition.
Man.
Yeah.
It's so hard when you're going from
ancient Hebrew and Aramaic and all this
different shit.
But do you think that this,
what you're saying is that someone would
do tricks to get you to listen to them,
like you levitate things or walk on
water or turn water into wine minds?
Moses splits the sea.
Like what?
Like,
you know,
I used to have a bit about that where it
was like,
um,
like there'd be like 100 people standing
behind him going,
how long can you hold that?
Like,
what the fuck is he doing?
Like why do you split the,
Oh,
we have to walk across that because
that's going to take dates.
I'm like,
how's he doing that magic.
Tell that silly motherfucker uses magic
and make us a boat.
It's crazy walking a mile high of on one
side or the other.
You just walking through the middle.
Just fucking dead fish flopping around
in the middle walls of water on either
side.
Yeah.
Very humid.
Fuck that.
Well,
I mean you're,
that's all,
you know,
that's literal interpretations.
It's something that's way deeper than.
That adds a lot of deeper meanings.
It's probably a,
you know,
it's a,
it's a myth.
They're using these encoded stories to
try to get across something that's a lot
bigger and it's isn't about really
walking on water maybe.
No,
no,
but I think that these showing that the
people that had all this knowledge also
had magic tricks is very telling.
Like the people that everybody would
follow.
They were.
They were able to do things right.
Like,
well,
how about the guy who I'm called upon a.
She bear to kill these kids that were
mocking him for being bald.
That's a story that's in the Bible.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There was a man,
I forget his name.
You can find that story.
He called a upon a.
She bear and God brought down a sheet
bear to smite these children that were
making fun of is balding.
She asked,
well,
I think it was a female bear.
They would.
They would do cold.
She bare back then to today,
they were,
I guess we'd call it a sow sow bear,
but that this bear killed the kids
because they were making fun of him for
being,
for being bald.
Like what?
Like,
you know,
there again,
you have to listen to this guy.
He's got magic is able to conjure up
from the forest to kill mocking
children.
Yeah.
They walk on water.
They turned water into wine here.
Why did God killed 42 lads merely for
saying Alicia was bald?
Forty two lads.
That makes it worse.
Friendly.
Or let's read the verse.
Then he went up from there to backfill.
Anyways,
going up,
by the way,
young lads came out from the city and
mocked him and said,
damn,
go app your bald.
Head Up.
You bought it.
When he looked behind him and saw them,
he cursed them in the name of the Lord.
It doesn't say what he says in all caps
too,
by the way,
like it's fucking twitter account.
Tooth then to feet.
Yeah,
Lord.
God.
Then to female bears,
came out of the woods and tore up 42
lads have their number.
I thought it was too too.
That's crazy.
It knows to bears either one.
She bear weight.
What is this?
So this is like actually exploring this.
Why would God allow two bears to kill 42
young black,
and it's written by a guy named Matt
Slick,
probably doing porn right now,
red liquid.
It says,
let's take a look.
Bitch.
You ain't taking nothing.
You're just guessing.
Alicia was traveling from Jericho to
Bethel when a group of young men
verbally accosted him.
A 42 is a large number of people and
they were probably an organized group,
gone out to challenge the La show.
Their mockery implied a militia to a
malicious intent,
especially when the culture of the time
insisted on showing respect to their
elders.
Furthermore,
the statement go up.
You bald head has cultural significance.
First of all,
go up in parenthesis is a probably a
reference to a licensed predecessor
Alijah ascending to heaven.
In other words,
they are stating that when Elijah got,
oh,
they want to lie Shangaan,
it's,
oh,
this is just so ridiculously intense.
Elijah had gone on to the next world.
The implication is they wanted
[inaudible] dead.
Also,
the epitaph,
bald head was one of contempt in the
east end.
Quotes apply to a person who,
a person,
even with a bushy head of hair lepers
had to shave
their heads,
is such a statement,
could easily have been deliberate,
malicious insult,
something dangerous.
And um,
yeah,
so it's such a weird interpretation of
what it is.
Either way you sent bears to kill people
for marketing your fucking head because
you're saying it's okay if they were
being disrespectful,
that God would just call some bears.
That this is the weirdest sort of a
justification for attack by,
by wild beasts.
The creator of the universe is using a
wild beast to attack because someone
hurt with words.
Have you read the book of Job?
Nothing since I was like,
it's so.
It's a whopper men.
So it's the story of this Guy Joe,
who's like prosperous.
He's in love,
he's married,
he has three children and lots of
animals and land and everything's going
great.
And so up in heaven or in wherever they
are,
God and the devil are having a
conversation and God is saying,
look at how great I am,
how everyone loves me.
And you know,
look at Joe.
He loves me.
He worships all the time and all that,
and the devil says,
of course he does because his life so
good take away is a sheep and see what
he says.
And God's like,
alright,
so he kills all job.
Sheep and job goes to church and
worships and no problem.
And then the devil's lake.
Yeah,
but if you took away the cows and the
land there,
then you'd see.
So God goes,
it takes away the cows and the land and
it goes on and on until job is totally
destitute.
All of his family is dead.
He sitting on an ash heap with boils all
over his body.
That's how far God was willing to go,
to prove a point to the devil.
Jesus Christ.
Remember that part?
Didn't.
He continued to love God.
That's a crazy story.
Sorry,
let me just finish.
So then what?
So then God wins the bet.
Whereas tortured this dude and he gives
back twice as much as everything to job
to reward him.
So now he has 400 sheep and one in six
children.
And it's like.
So it didn't matter who those children
were that you killed.
And the wife,
you just give them another wife and more
children.
You're better.
Maybe had a little time machine spun it
all back.
I mean he did create the universe.
He could do whatever the fuck you want.
That is kind of like the part in job.
That's.
I mean again,
literally.
Yeah,
it's fucking ridiculous.
But it's not supposed to be stories that
are meant to like encompass the human
predicament and like one of the cool
things in there isn't there?
This great line where job is like
questioning why he would job is
questioning him too or something.
He said something.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
He,
they get into an argument.
Response is something like I created.
Yeah.
Where were you when I created the
heavens and the earth?
And this is again man,
the fucking tone.
And at this debt,
this tribal desert religion is really
harsh and patriarchal.
But the message behind it,
it's pretty similar.
The bhagavad Gita,
which is
just a fucking battlefield where Krishna
turns into that universal form is the
quote ob Oppenheimer's quote,
behold,
I have become damn become the destroyer
of worlds.
And so it's a similar thing.
Both of these are saying,
listen,
tiny little human thing all caught up in
your life,
so fixated on everything about you.
You exist within the infinite span of
time.
A Big Bang to go with something like we
were saying longer than 13 point 7
billion years.
You tiny,
tiny little thing.
You exist in something so infinitely
gigantic and beautiful.
What do you think you control?
What do you think you really control?
You don't control shit.
You don't control anything,
so that's what they really.
It's more of like when when we
experienced inevitable catastrophe in
our lives and we're looking around and
like,
what the fuck,
man,
what the fuck's wrong with the universe?
It's like nothing's wrong with the
universe.
Nothing's wrong with you.
Nothing's wrong with anything.
In fact,
everything's perfect.
Just surrender to it.
Even if you're sitting in the goddamn
ash pile covered in boils,
if you just let go and surrender and
drop the bitterness,
then you can.
If nothing else,
not suffer under the terrible weight of
the resistance or feeling like a victim.
That's,
to me what I get at a job,
you know,
from the non literal level,
the literal level.
It's like God's hanging out with Satan,
so they played poker and shit.
What does that mean?
Like he just drops by like Satan
sometimes just pops by wherever God
lives and they make bets.
They make beds.
It's ridiculous,
but it will suffer for God's bet like
fear factor when you think about it.
No,
you got paid for Fairfax.
Perfect.
If you.
When you made $50,000
job,
the government takes a piece out of
someone winning naked and afraid or any
of those shows.
Government takes piece.
That's crazy.
You're out there choking on bug.
Dick's trying to make banana hammock out
of literal banana leaves for Dick by
love or biting you everywhere.
It's so ridiculous.
Those shows are so ridiculous.
It's amazing.
They haven't killed anybody.
It is Kong.
How come nobody's gotten bitten by
spiders and died or some shit?
Some people get super sick on the show.
Oh yeah.
Well they eat fucked up things.
By the way,
some of this stuff,
if you eat things and don't cook them,
those parasites can stay with you
forever,
so I don't do Sushi.
Sushi is not bad if you get ocean Sushi,
but I've been told not to eat salmon.
I've been told,
yeah,
someone said that.
Freshwater Salmon.
The problem is salmon is a freshwater
fish as well.
They go,
they migrate to go to the ocean and they
go and they're susceptible to some
parasites apparently that a tuna and a
lot of ocean born fish isn't susceptible
to because I guess the parents don't.
They just live way easier and fresh
water,
which makes sense,
right?
Yeah.
Also the salmon stop eating and their
metabolism changes once they get back to
fresh water and so essentially they're
dying from that point on,
you know,
so when you see them upstream there,
they're like zombies.
It's really gross.
Sushi is a really nutty thing when you
stop and think about it,
right?
Because here we are,
we're,
we're like on these little landmasses
surrounded by a blue.
Like as soon as you get to the edge,
you realize how much blue there and
you're like,
Holy Shit,
that's all water.
Like,
yeah,
yeah.
We'll just so accustomed to it.
No big deal.
It's just water.
So.
No,
no,
it's this thing is mostly water.
We're on the dirt spots of this thing.
That's mostly water.
Yeah.
Well we do is we take these metal boxes
and we float out there and we grab
whatever is live and we scoop it up with
nets and fucking bring it in Bro.
It's great.
We serve it with a little bit of
Jalapeno on top and some ponds do sauce.
You're gonna.
Love it and we're just extracting the
fish out of the water ever.
Just pulling them out.
It's the only thing like it in terms of
that fact that we're not dealing with
farmed animals were scooping up wild
animals.
We don't allow that anymore in the
United States,
like the United States,
you don't use the age to have market
hunting for buffalo and for elk and for
deer.
You're not allowed to do that anymore.
That's illegal.
Now.
Wild game is wild,
but not wild fish,
wild fish.
You can commercially farm,
you could commercially cultivated and
harvest you go out there with giant
fucking nets and just scoop up wild
creatures in the middle of the ocean
because we don't have good regulations
for the fucking ocean.
So 80 percent of what you bring up that
you killed.
Oh yes.
Throw it over.
We're just draining that thing.
We're draining and it's wild.
It's a wild thing.
If like we,
if anybody tried to propose that today
with like elk,
someone said,
we're just going to get nets and just
run through the forest and gather up all
the elk and then we're going to sell it
at the ELC store.
You'd be like the fuck you are right the
fuck you are,
man.
Those things are wild and kill all the
Iraqi tunes and squirrels.
So you're decimating the environment and
monkeys,
they,
you know,
the,
the nets are super a work.
They work really hard,
you know what I mean?
Pulling through all that water.
Two or three trips,
they cut them loose.
They don't pull them back up to the boat
and recycle them.
They cut them loose.
So oceans are full of drifting nets,
miles wide,
just going on and killing more and more
shit until they finally say no.
Yeah.
Because as you say,
it's this kind of wilderness now where
it's unregulated largely and there's no
way to look at it and see all that Shit,
you know?
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
It's really freaked me out.
Just thinking of the sheer numbers of
nets drifting through the water and
landing on the ground.
I know that because a friend of mine was
working with a guy who was,
if I remember this correctly,
it's in Chile,
I think kyle who's a,
he's a surfer,
goes around the world and does
interesting research.
And uh,
he was in Chile and there was a guy
starting a company that was created a
market for those nets to encourage the
fisherman to bring them back.
And then he recycled that,
that nylon,
because it's a pretty high quality
nylon.
So the whole idea is he's,
he's created a sustainable business
selling these things made from the nylon
that people know comes from the nylon.
Wow.
This is crazy.
Ghost fishing.
Yeah.
So they just go around.
Oh Man,
I had a talking about Sushi.
I had a really traumatic experience with
that in Alaska that have I told you,
you know,
so I,
I met this dude on the ferry going up.
Really Cool Guy Ed from Oregon
somewhere.
He was camping next to me on the deck of
a,
the ferry boat and next to him was this
really hot woman,
Becca and Becca never changed her
clothes in like three or four days on
the ferry.
Really sexy but never changed her
clothes.
Never opened her backpack.
She had this huge backpack.
Finally it turned out it was full of
weed.
She was smuggling from Hawaii to Alaska.
Yeah.
Wow.
So Ed sort of fell in love with her.
We get to this town and we get off.
I bet.
Ads like all into fishing.
Yeah,
exactly.
She's got it all bad.
So anyway,
he's super into fishing.
His dream,
his whole life has been to go to Alaska
and fish.
Wow.
He's got this Super Nice Rod,
carbon rod and all this stuff and I
don't know shit about fishing,
but we were in Petersburg,
Alaska and we go out.
I walk out with them.
I'm a vegetarian,
but anyway,
he casts first cast.
He catches the salmon,
big salmon,
brings it in and kills it with a rock
and all that.
And then another.
He's super happy.
It's his dream.
Everything's wonderful.
We go back to this campsite where we are
and there's like a maybe 10 tents around
in this campground and it's central area
with a fire and all that.
And he so happy because he's going to
feed everybody.
He's got these three fish,
he's feeling great and he's so he's got,
you know,
puts a onions and shit inside and the
foil and all that.
And everybody's hanging out.
Everybody's super happy.
He passes out the fish,
he's got his own smaller one is for him.
Everyone else is sharing the other two.
And I'm sitting up behind him looking
over his shoulder and I see movement in
this fish and I'm like,
hi.
And we'd been drinking and it's
firelight,
but I'm pretty sure I see movement and I
looked closer over shoulder and there's
all these tiny little white worms at the
center of the fish that hadn't been
cooked out.
And they're all just moving,
moving like Sylvia.
Right?
Oh my God.
How many of you had a bite already know
I'm a vegetarian.
Oh,
that's right.
At that point,
right?
So I didn't need any.
And it's like the best night of his
life.
Oh my God.
And I'm a.
I got tell him.
Yes,
right.
He's already eaten
half the fish.
Oh Jesus.
Oh.
So I say,
ed man,
stop.
Look,
look at this.
And he sees it and he's just like,
oh fuck.
He goes from the top of the world to the
bottom,
grabs this bottle of Tequila drinks half
this bottle of Tequila it to try to kill
what's in his stomach work.
I don't know.
It's a great idea.
Probably would work guys.
Thank you.
It was just a good excuse to get fucked
up and stub my toe.
Kimmy.
That Tequila quit.
Got fired.
Fuck you mean it.
Tequila quick.
Whatever happens.
Tequila.
I need half a bottle of Tequila on the
devil.
Will Tequila means cure all in Spanish.
Oh man,
got me to.
Damn.
Yeah,
that's the worms are fucking scary shit,
man.
That guy that a ref.
The guy who escaped North Korea,
so they found enormous tapeworms in his
body.
His body.
He was like,
I think they described it as a toy that
had been broken,
like it was just broken like all over
the place,
like legs are broken bones or broken.
His insides are filled with parasites.
You got nutrition or times or something.
Yeah.
Good shot four times here.
The whole thing is horrific,
man.
That poor fucking guy,
That poor fucking guy for Dune is
falling apart.
He gets short shot four times and he
keeps running.
Yeah.
That's how bad he wanted to get free,
I guess.
Yeah,
the videos and Naomi,
you seen it?
No,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
It's just making this run for it and
they jumped out the car and they're
shooting at me like really close
distance while he's running.
I mean,
I didn't realize that they were that
close to them.
They were on the ground like 15,
20 feet away from him shooting at him as
he's running,
as he jumped out of his car.
You know,
it's crazy.
Is that video of that fucking dude from
North Korea and the airport getting that
poison put on him?
No,
I haven't seen that.
Oh,
Kim Jong.
UN's brother?
Yeah.
Kim Jongens brothers video.
The assassination.
Watch it.
It's why me is on it.
It's pretty intense.
What was it,
seren?
Is that what they put on him?
I don't know what it was.
Some nerve gas.
They,
they trick someone to doing that for
them.
Right.
It wasn't a story.
A defense of the people who did it.
They're saying they didn't know,
but apparently there was footage of them
practicing it.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's him afterwards.
That's him after getting zapped.
But you can watch like a professional
assassination.
Yeah.
Ready at the airport and apparently he
had the antidote in his baggage.
Oh Jesus Christ.
This is the thing with the them having
like Icbm Vieques,
vieques that 20 minutes after VX
poisoning.
Just how nutty.
I mean this is.
This is some old school shit that they
do in the Soviet Union to write a bunch
of people over there have been killed
with poisoned in London.
Actually the.
There they are
there right there.
Just vx gas.
Mr.
Like puts a chloroform rag over his
face.
She just walks over and put the rag on
his head and they're going to show
another video where you watch just comes
up behind him.
Fluid is low.
That's all it takes to kill you.
That's fucking insane.
And he's saying someone just put
something on my face.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
That's insane.
Yeah,
it's not scary.
Can't see that coming.
So you stay in there and she just walks
right up and jack.
So whoa.
She was fast too.
That's intense,
man.
That's intense.
So my buddy had got medivaced out of
Petersburg with the worms in his
stomach,
intestinal bleeding.
Jesus Christ.
They were trying to burrow the way out.
Yep.
Eat his bones on the inside.
This is your friend who drank that
Tequila doesn't work to get rid of one.
Killed them all.
He went to the doctor the next day in
town and the doctor was like,
yeah,
it's probably no big deal.
Whatever you'll be.
Fuck you doctor.
And then I left and traveled all around
Alaska and then went back home and when
I was home I got a letter from him that
he had been medivaced out and had been
in the hospital,
had four or five surgeries.
How many other people fucked up?
I don't know if he'd lived a fish.
You don't know if he lived.
How many other people got sick?
Just his story.
If you just trust him,
the other fish were fine.
Could you go and find out for the story
so we know how we should feel.
I don't like these open ended a fucking
ed was.
He lived in the country for old men type
end.
They lived happily ever after too,
to tell you guys seen that video.
That cam girl who's like a worm shoots
at her ass,
hope everyone seemed.
Oh my God,
we did.
Jamie can know if it's on instagram.
I haven't seen it.
He squats down and it's like just the
very tip of some kind of worm thing like
pops out of her ass and sex back.
Jamie seen this.
Maybe I dreamed it.
I'm pretty sure you might.
It might not.
How interesting is it that there's two
completely different social media
platforms that we all use?
Twitter and instagram and one of them
allow straight up porn.
Which one?
Twitter.
Twitter,
a straight up porn on your feet and you
see a chick just gagging on a fat dick
taking one right in the ass right there,
right at your feet and you're like,
whoa.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What is that?
Instagram wanted to be show nipples,
drills,
blends,
blurted,
nipples out.
Yeah.
You got to put like little acorns is.
What it's really interesting is because
my eyesight's going shitty anyway,
so if a girl is mildly billers or
Nipples,
to me it looks the same.
So you're getting around
just getting around,
playing the system built in system.
No,
for real though,
how blurry does it happen?
This is the question like would you see
like a picture of my Dick?
Right?
If you have a picture of you sitting
there and you want it to go on
Instagram,
you would that Hawaiian shirt on,
Chris with your hog hanging out and you
want to take a picture of slightly
pixelate your Dick.
He'll be like really clear where the
head of it is,
where the balls are,
where the shaft is.
Even the color of your deck will be very
easy to start,
but it's not totally your deck because
it's all pixely.
Oh there,
look.
Oh,
okay.
Show it from the beginning.
I look.
Watch a seems like a worm that's seems
like she'd get parasites internally.
Pixelation thing is one of them.
Thanks for bringing that to our
attention.
Not Be Real.
I mean that wasn't the highest quality.
That could have been like some CGI even
more fucked up than CGI and worms and
they cam girls assholes or.
But if it was where I'm coming out of
her ass hole,
because you really suck it back in like
that.
I mean it's an asshole.
It's not lips.
It's like it sucked itself back in.
Yeah.
But you don't have a lung connected to
your asshole.
Like how much are you sucking?
How much power does she have to get that
Spaghetti back into her mouth?
The wiring itself pulled its head back
in.
It was like,
whoa.
Another universe looking at me.
The camera.
Fuck this.
I know,
right?
She used to that steady.
90 six degrees.
Yeah.
It's cozy.
Wow.
How weird,
man.
That we can get those.
I had a dog once,
it had worms and when she would go to
the bathroom,
that's how I found it.
I saw worms,
inner poop and I saw worms like around
her butthole and I was like,
oh,
someone's got a problem.
And they do that as drag across the
carpet will dogsled they eat everything,
man,
you know,
they'll eat anything.
They find a dead rat.
They just start eating it and they'd get
all kinds of fucked up things inside
their body.
Oh Shit,
man.
If you seen that documentary.
Wait,
he.
God dammit.
I can't believe I can't remember his
name.
He's the guy who like only ate
McDonald's for Morgan spurlock.
Have you seen Morgan spurlock's rats?
Yes.
Oh my God.
When they.
When they dissect the rack and you see
what's living in that thing.
I about that bought fly that was in its
neck.
Literally like if you had a football
grown out of your side of your neck.
That's how big this Bot fly larva was.
It's called red.
It's on Netflix.
It's called rats.
It is fucked up and it's so good.
So good.
It's so good,
man.
But it is so deeply disturbing.
The raw numbers that you get hit with
you.
Like what?
Wait a minute.
Is that real?
Like when you,
when you hear there's as many rats in
New York City as there are human beings
and you just go,
wait,
wait a minute.
Really?
Yeah.
There's the whole.
That's from the butterfly larva.
They pulled out of that things body.
Jesus.
Yeah,
and they said that there were so many of
them that they tested that have like
terminal illnesses in them to just
fucking everywhere to man and in New
York they set this camera up while those
garbage bags were being put out and you
see the ratchet darn out of the sewer
and then they stuck cameras down to
sewer hose to find them and they learn
about poisonous and they'll piss on it
to warrant or they'll send in,
didn't they?
Didn't he say they'll send in like like
Beta rats to the poison?
Yeah,
the sending Beta rats and they get stuck
in traps and they get they poison and
they'll sit back and they'll watch and
you can observe them do this.
They literally,
yeah,
they literally send the dumber or routes
for their.
They're like all things we were talking
about earlier,
they're like a super organism,
a rats.
Rats are all basically the same shape
and size.
They vary a little bit bigger,
a little bit smaller,
but mostly the same thing.
Who Look exactly the same and they
behave like the same.
They do,
they all do the same shit and they all
move into these and they're.
They're happy to live with.
Nothing else wants to live like we'll
take it,
we'll moving in and they move in and
breed in a way that's unprecedented in
terms of things that like mammals that
live alongside humans,
there's not a goddamn thing like rats,
like no other animals figured out how to
do it.
Like Rats,
k like they can do it in a way where
this as many of them as there was a bus.
Just imagine that there's smart.
His father must be a lot of cockroaches.
Probably,
I would guess more than there are rats,
right?
Sure.
Because they're so small.
Oh yeah,
but those tools are like particular
things.
It's really interesting because people
don't like to.
They always want to think that they
never.
They never prejudge.
They're not prejudice,
but we certainly are.
When it comes to rats and bugs.
Butterflies are awesome.
Butterfly landed on you.
Everybody's psyched.
Roche walks in the room,
everybody freaks out.
Wants to fucking stop it,
get it.
Get it right.
Yeah.
Mosquito comes in.
Everybody's pissed.
Spider walks in,
AH,
some people freak out.
Some people want to help the spider.
Yeah,
man,
when you see any kind of rat rats are no
Bueno.
Like to the core.
You see that rat and you're like that.
And a squirrel.
Squirrels are cool.
Just rats with bushy tail per well.
They don't eat meat.
That's the thing about squirrels.
Squirrels were eating acorns and shit.
That is just a better animal,
but they do eat meat sometimes.
Here's the fucked up thing about
animals,
especially if there's,
you know,
they're sick or they have some weird
nutrition requirement.
There's a video of a squirrel eating a
mouse and it's hard to watch.
Man.
The squirrel was holding onto this mouth
mouse with its hands and just chewing
into it.
A fucking score.
And you're like,
Whoa,
really?
This is a real trusted you.
Yeah,
you're a fucking squirrel.
You're supposed to
be super cool.
I could feed you like you could.
Like there it is.
Look at it,
but you always think,
well you started it with the warm in the
ass,
but it's been downhill from there.
I'm excited to look at that.
It's insane because he doesn't have any
problem eating that rap.
He's watching a movie.
It's like he's watching game of thrones,
like enjoying some quickies devouring.
It seems like it's like you holding onto
a ham cream cone.
Look at that because it's biting into
it.
Delicious.
Looking at it.
It's almost gone.
Jesus.
No,
I dropped a big chunk.
Oh,
he dropped.
So looking at these giant chunks of
guts.
It's consuming.
He was hungry.
This is amazing,
man.
It's too bad.
The only audience he's bearing what's
left of it.
This is a ground squirrel.
This is a different kind of squirrel.
That might be why ground squirrels are a
totally different kind of squirrel.
Ground.
Squirrels are actually a real problem on
ranches because they make millions.
Yeah.
They estimate to honed ranch is 270,000
acres and someone there told me,
I didn't check this true,
but just listen if it is told me that
the biomass of these ground squirrels is
bigger than anything else on the ranch
because these tiny little things there
so fucking many of them that all the
deer,
all the bear or the mountain lions,
all the wild pigs,
all the cattle that roam around there,
all the elk,
everything,
every other bird,
ground,
nesting birds,
Turkeys,
everything.
The biomass of those fucking ground
squirrels was greater than all of it.
He's like,
I just want you to think about that for
a second.
I was like,
what?
He's like,
we got a real problem with these things.
He goes,
you can't kill them,
and they leave holes and then the cattle
step in those holes and break their
ankles.
You can't kill him because they're just
too wildly where you gotta find them,
sit out there with a pistol and you're
going to shoot it like poison or is what
he said.
He said he shot one of them and when he
shot it,
another one grabbed it and dragged it
into the hole to eat it.
Dude.
Eating it.
Yeah.
Not find out if ground nesting squirrels
eat meat.
If ground nesting squirrels are
omnivores,
I wonder if they have a just a totally
different diet because the they have
those gross tails to.
They have almost rat tails.
The gross little things.
You don't feel good or when you're
around them.
That's why we need more snakes.
Yeah.
We don't need more snakes.
Snakes.
Snakes are one of the only things that
all babies are afraid of.
Instinctively.
Show an infant the new image of a snake
and they'll just freak.
Well,
that's [inaudible] in the garden of
Eden.
The snake is what made eve eat
the tree of the knowledge of Jesus.
True.
He's right though.
That's true.
Snakes fault.
Eaves a good chick.
Most neotropic.
Ground squirrels are omnivorous.
Or you go.
There you go.
So they're eating meat.
Ground oral sex.
Caterpillar's crooked mice and make each
other.
Oh,
they get in there and eat the eggs
rather than asked.
Yeah.
Ground nesting birds.
Ducks.
Yeah.
Eggs and chicks and ducks and birds.
Mice.
Smaller ground squirrels.
Oh yeah.
So squirrels.
Ground squirrels are just little
monsters.
Yeah.
That's why we feel bad about them.
They're the little evil little
mediators.
So what?
Coyotes,
I guess probably get something.
Yeah,
but the problem is they dig into holes
and the coyotes have a hard time
catching them.
Too dark to that fucking hole so quick.
I don't think it's an effective method.
I don't think they have a lot of
effective methods of eradicating them
other than like poison and shit.
If I had a guest.
What about those?
Rat Terriers in the spurlock shot?
Remember that?
God,
it was amazing.
They actually hunt rats.
I haven't seen the film though.
They tear these rats apart.
They live for it.
So they live for.
They are in their glory when they let
them loose with these terriers.
Go correct.
That's like Jack Russel terriers and
that's why those little fuckers are so
hyper because they're rat killers.
It's like it's fucking dawn and the
dad's like watching zombies them apart.
It is the grab and shake.
I'm so happy right now.
This is the greatest thing that happens
to these dogs is hunting.
Fucking look at that and go,
Oh yeah,
look at the fucking rat.
Try to get away.
And they just shaking it.
Whoa.
That is amazing.
Yeah.
I guess the guys are helping them that
they're digging them up.
Yeah.
That's the idea.
God.
Laughter of children as you're watching
her mother get ripped apart by monsters
there in the dirt here and that.
These,
these guys are digging them out of the
hole.
And as they dig them out of the holes,
the rats explained the dogs know that.
Go to look for it.
Yeah.
Wagging their tails.
There's so happy,
dude.
It's so nuts.
It's crazy.
You can almost engineer any animal.
Oh,
there's one.
Got It.
Jesus Christ moving.
Yeah.
And then what did they do?
They're not eating them apart.
They were tearing them apart.
They're eating.
Just like killing him.
Well,
they probably eat so much.
They're stuffed now that just,
uh,
I'm sure they eat some of it though and
that's a whole thing of that last one.
It looked like he was bringing it over,
like maybe they're trained to put them
in a bag or something.
That would be clutch.
Maybe you got to do something with the
body's a golden retrievers and stuff.
Right.
Then the ducks.
Why?
Why,
why are you so fascinated with this part
in nature?
Like sometimes I got to be careful with
your feet,
man,
because it's like.
I know man,
if you like,
if like you,
I don't look at it.
But yeah,
inevitably if you tweet nature's,
what do you say?
Nature's
bitch.
Uh,
no.
He says nature is.
What do you say?
What's the thing you say native friends
are scary.
Birch,
something like that.
If I see that I'm not watching this,
she's going to be awful.
Let's get.
But why do you.
Why do you?
Yeah,
why are you so interested in that aspect
of nature?
Well,
super extreme,
right?
I mean this is an extreme event
happening here.
One life form is exploding on another
life form and it seems like it's
designed to do that.
When you see a Jaguar,
Kyla Cayman and grab it in the back of
its neck and bite into a fucking
crocodile and drag it in between its
legs,
up the beach to eat it.
You're seeing one of the most extreme
things that exists in the world.
You're seeing a life form consuming
another life form with its face,
killing her,
like eliminating it from us dimension
with its teeth at a very specific part
of its body and it seems like it's
designed to do that and that's the only
way you keep these populations and
control the populations have a built in
system and we want to look at it through
the gobs of our civilization and through
what we've accepted.
This is a pet and this is an animal that
you eat and you never eat.
Your pat and we have all these weird
little sort of distinctions and cultural
ideas that we've attached to animal
life,
but he watched them in their world.
Their world is fucking.
It's unbelievably ruthless,
unbelievably ruthless.
Like our ideas of animals have become so
strange because we keep,
some of them,
we keep them around us and we feed them
so they're like really sweet to us,
but there's not a fucking animal in all
of nature that is so sweet with the
other animals around it.
Just many animals that are sweet with
the other animals around them.
All hurt animals for example.
No,
that's what I mean.
Social,
what I mean like Jaguars and antelopes
aren't buddies.
Well,
when the Jaguar is eaton,
he can walk right through the middle of
the hurt and they won't even run away
because they know he's not hungry.
Oh,
but that's so crazy to think that's like
a murderer and kills one of your buddies
and eat something.
You'll be cool just wandering around
that,
but they're not visitors.
They're eating.
Their interactions are incredibly
ruthless when they wrap it,
but see I.
This is something I write about in this
book I'm working on still,
which is the lack of proportionality in
this argument because what's your.
This nature is ruthless red in tooth and
claw thing.
That's been very popular for a long
time,
but the real well it's real when it's
real,
but it's also real that we die in agony
and often our agony is extended by
medicine to last much longer than that
mouse that just got eaten by the score.
I'm fascinated by death by these
interactions,
but what I'm saying is that the,
the conclusion to draw from those
interactions that therefore nature is
this battlefield misrepresents what
actually happens in nature when
predation happens,
it can be nasty of.
Right,
but that's
what I'm saying.
I'm not looking at the entire nature as
a whole and making this distinction.
This is the only thing interesting about
nature.
No,
no,
no.
I'm saying when I just the depiction of
nature as being ruthless.
Well,
it is in that moment that is nature and
that isn't that moment and in that
moment exists.
The only reason why these predators can
exist is because they have to be killing
things all over the world.
I mean,
every place where there's a wolf,
it means the wolf is alive because it's
eating things,
which means it's killing things all day
long.
I mean,
that's not a.
that's not an inaccurate depiction.
The thing is there's so many things.
There's so many elk exist,
so many wolves.
Most of the time the elk aren't getting
killed by wolves,
but wolves are killing an elk almost
every store,
so it's just a matter how you look at
it.
So it's just,
it's correct to say diminishing the
ruthless aspect of it because you're
looking at the overall picture,
but.
But I'm not diminishing it.
What I'm saying is that that's one
perspective on it and actually in terms
of proportion,
it's a minor perspective on it.
For example,
I was watching this nature thing and
there were these seals playing in the
waves and then the du Du du Du du Du du
Du to start in this great white comes up
and hits one of the seals and they slow
it down to one 40th natural speeds.
ORC.
All right,
well I think it was a great way.
It may have been an Orca at same,
same thing,
and this seal lands in its mouth and you
see a crunching the seal and the blood
running down and the narration is nature
is ruthless and there's the never ending
struggle for survival and Yada,
Yada,
and so I'm looking at that.
I'm thinking,
how long do harbor seals live?
So I look it up.
Online.
Harbor Seals live about 25 to 30 years.
I've seen a lot of seals lying around on
rocks,
having a good time not stressed out.
I don't see a lot of high stress seals
and so I think it's like,
okay,
this seal,
let's say live 25 years.
It's hanging out eating Sushi,
having a good time.
Then boom,
it's dead so quickly that we have to
slow this down to one 40th of normal
speed so you can enjoy this death porn.
That's a tiny sliver of that seals
existence and we're depicting nature as
this incredibly ruthless,
horrible.
We'll
bloody place.
That's just inaccurate.
Well,
it's not in that moment.
Not In that moment,
but you can't ignore that in moment.
No,
of course not.
That moment is the reason,
but that moment is the reason why this
seals population is controlled moment is
the reason why the shark can.
Oh yeah.
It all has to be there.
I agree with you,
but I disagree with you.
I agree with you.
I see you're saying that there's way
more going on than just as tooth Fang
claw.
I don't.
I'm not looking at it from a moral
perspective.
I'm looking at it from a like a chaotic
I'm like,
it is fascinating.
These to these schools of tuna that we
scoop up with nets.
They're out there,
Jack and little fish.
That's why they're in schools because
they operate more efficiently that way
and they're chasing down sardines and
fucking them up and that's oftentimes
how you catch fish.
When I was in,
when I was a tuna fishing in Mexico,
we're catching amberjack or skipjack,
I forget,
but you would find these pools of bait
fish bullet going crazy on the surface
of the water because the tune and were
all ganging up on and Jack it up and
then he got the Pelicans and top attack.
Cc the birds and then you would see the
froth of the water and then these fish
would just.
They'd go crazy and fuck up these little
bait fish and you would literally just
cast into this football field size
swirling in the ocean and these fish
would just bite it and you would just
catch them up almost instantly so that
that is not the whole ocean all the
time,
but that's still real.
Like this is real.
I'm not denying the reality.
I'm talking to proportion.
I agree,
but the thing that I find the most
fascinating for whatever fucked up
reason is when the water,
the water buffalo comes out the line and
the line ducks under the water buffalo
and grabs it by its neck and rolled it
over and crushes it.
Saying,
I just,
I am fascinated by the idea that all
moral judgments aside nature has somehow
engineered a Jaguar and a cayman,
and then there's Jaguar looked at Cayman
was like,
ah,
to figure out how to put that in me.
And he snuck up,
swam in the water,
snuck up on a goddamn crocodile,
shopped on its back.
It's an equity.
There's a lot of cool shit.
I like watching.
Jaguars is real.
I liked watching Jaguars when they get
ahold of psychedelic plants.
Have you ever seen that?
There's a,
there's this type of vine that's rich
and dmt that Jaguars will chew on and
then they literally just lie on their
back and they're just staring out into
space trip and balls like catnip for
Jaguar.
But if they think it's Psychedelic,
they think that might be when you have
all these Jaguar dreams,
when people take Iowasca,
it might be that the Jaguar is
interfacing with the same dimension that
you will.
Oh,
so that's the reason why.
Because we know that these jaguars do
take these psychedelic plants and we
know that these psychedelic plants,
when they were first discovered,
they were trying to call.
I'm harming,
is uh,
the,
the uh,
the chemical,
but they were trying to call it
telepathy theme was the same as harming.
They had to run tests on it and find out
that there was,
it was already an established molecule
that was an already established a
compound.
So the reason why they call it telepathy
was because people were experiencing
group states of consciousness while they
were taking this stuff,
so they're thinking that these people
that do Iowasca and have these trips
with Jaguars,
they literally might be interacting with
Jaguars who were also tripping.
Like I see this thing is just eating
these leaves and lion dyads back clearly
in an altered state,
just rolling around on its back with its
paws up in the air,
staring at things that aren't there
staring at.
It's like in Brooklyn right now with a
bunch of fucking people on some loft in
Brooklyn with some fucking glass
blowers.
A couple of accountants.
Its eyes dilate.
It's mine's going back and forth.
That is so fucking wild.
I'm going to Peru in a couple of weeks.
You're going to get down with the funky
funky medicine plant medicine.
Yeah.
If the right situation presents itself,
that's the thing,
right?
The problem and the people that say
plant medicine,
they all make go,
oh yeah.
They're like really into like other the
plant medicine.
You're like,
okay,
yeah.
Okay.
You might be cool if you used those
terms all the time or you might be one
of those fucking Weirdos.
You know,
there's,
there's a bunch of people that are into
the psychedelic world that they know
they would have been into the moonies if
the moonies found them.
Right.
There are lots of different plants that
they use though.
It's not just Iowasca,
so if you just use it as a general term
there,
San Pedro and all the time.
I'm fully aware.
It's just the people love saying it.
Yeah.
They love saying.
I mean legally it's probably better to
use the term plant medicine.
It is so pretentious that aren't going
to get you stopped at any borders.
Yeah,
I think it's pretentious.
Like I get it.
I understand why you're calling it a
plant medicine,
but like when I'm getting stoned,
I'm not thinking,
let me take my medicine.
I'm thinking,
let me get.
I want to get fucking high man.
I wanna I wanna like get high play with
synthesizers.
When I'm like,
when I'm taking Roba Tesson I'm thinking
I'm taking medicine right now.
It tastes like shit.
It's gonna.
Make me fall asleep.
I just honestly,
the reason I don't like the term plant
medicine is because I think it,
and forgive me out there you guys,
but I feel like in some small way
diminishes all the other reasons I want
to take this fucking plant.
Like when I'm,
when I'm like,
you know,
and this is such a degraded thing to
say,
so I'm sorry,
but remember when used to be sponsored
by fleshlight.
Yes.
And you fucked a flashlight,
right?
And it made you come shut.
You weren't thinking as you're fucking
the flashlight for the pure joy of like
experiencing an orgasm with this weird
dumb thing.
This tube.
You're not thinking to yourself,
I'm giving myself medicine.
Now you're thinking,
I don't want to assume this is you for
you,
for I want to come in the same way like
with some of these substances that he'd
never get high with you again,
man.
The fucking house plants.
It's just sometimes it's a plant
medicine sometimes.
Why do you get high?
Are you saying that sometimes you get
high just because it feels good to
behind?
That's exactly what I'm saying.
That's why God made nitric oxide.
Can didn't you get your license with me
from a black guy with dreadlocks was a
doctor,
was calling it the medicine wasn't a,
didn't you?
And I go to that place.
I don't remember this.
This was in the early days when it was
like sketchy,
sketchy,
regrow ops were sketchy.
He didn't want people to know.
Where you grow up was it wasn't legal
across the board.
You had to get a doctor's
recommendation.
I remember we walked into the doctor's
office.
Tell me if you remember this.
It was just cool black guy with
dreadlocks and he had one of those
volcano vapor bags,
but it was extra long.
He made an extra long bag,
like a normal volcano.
Bay bags like that big.
He had one that was like three feet was.
It was cartoonish and as soon as he saw
us like,
y'all look sick,
need medicine,
come on man,
y'all need to layer.
And it was baked out of his fucking
mind.
He was a legitimate doctor and he had
full on dreadlocks.
No,
that wasn't me.
I wasn't with you.
I would not that.
That was not me,
but you know,
again,
it is healing.
I think it is a medicine and it can be.
Obviously it's in Madison.
It is a medicine that heals people for
sure.
I just think it's not just a medicine.
I think it's much more than that.
Maybe we just don't have the language to
describe what it is necessarily yet,
but people aren't or aren't taken
Iowasca to field good.
But it's not like a recreational drug.
Oh yeah.
You know what?
I agree with you there,
but I think that a lot of people are not
necessarily taking Iowasca because they
are.
They want something more out of their
life.
They want to.
They were or they want some novelty.
They want a heightened experience.
Many people are taking your Iwatch is
they're chronically fucking depressed
and they're desperate and they need help
and the people who are administering it
that are legitimate,
they,
they're like dog.
They're like doctors.
Their understanding of these plants is
as astounding and deep and I get all
that and,
and I,
I,
and I'm,
and I'm so.
I'm certainly not opposed to that
concept.
I'm just saying the term plant medicine
itself,
it feels like somehow it's less romantic
than I picture psychedelics,
to me,
psychedelics or a combination,
a hedonic tool,
a portal,
a means of communion,
a spiritual practice,
um,
and also in medicine.
But there are all those other things
too.
I just think it's more than a medicine.
That's all.
It's something bigger than medicine
though.
All those things I just mentioned you
could call it medicine.
It's just reducing either some expansion
of healing to that goes beyond the
physical and into the psychological and
emotional and spiritual,
you know,
which makes me sound like a Hippie,
but I just got schooled.
I was using the term hallucinogens
reflexively and I had Jim Fadiman on my
podcast who's the microdosing guru and
he very quickly said,
you know,
the,
the Scott,
a lot of baggage,
Hulu,
because you don't actually hallucinate,
you know,
and it's like,
well,
you're right.
Psychedelics is,
is definitely a better word for it.
It's a better term.
But what is happening when you're
closing your eyes when you're doing dmt?
I think it's,
it's entirely likely that we don't know.
And that you,
you might be actually interfacing with
some other place,
but you're seeing things that seemed
like they must be hallucinations.
Yeah.
It seems like something is interacting
with your visual perception abilities
where your eyes are seeing things that
are impossible.
Now is that because you're actually
there and you actually are experiencing
these impossible things or is it a trick
that's happening with chemicals and your
eyeballs and your brain and
neurochemistry and that's.
That's a question to be answered by
people far smarter than I.
and what is the difference between those
two things?
To what extent is your experience your
reality?
Yeah.
That's the real question,
right?
We want to think that if you can't weigh
something on a scale,
if I can bang on it with a hammer,
if I can't draw on it with a marker,
then it's not a real thing.
Right?
Right,
right.
But if you said this,
like if you had an experience with God
where you literally were transported
into heaven and you had a communication
with God and then God gave you love and
wisdom and then you came back down to
Earth into your body and you this
actually did happen,
or you took a drug and the exact same
experience took place in every way,
shape and form the exact amount of time,
the exact feeling,
the exact message,
the exact visuals,
the exact reexamining of your life when
you return,
they're basically the same thing.
I mean,
if less you could get God in one of them
tuna nets and bring them back here so I
could prove that you had God and that
you weren't just tripping your fucking
balls off basically telling me a story,
Bro.
Yeah,
that'd be pissed.
Yeah.
I think,
I don't know.
I'm sure that there's like a lot of
scientific materialist hearing that and
they're like,
they're,
they're assholes.
Or like squeezing into their body.
Just in horror what you're saying,
because it's like they're,
they're like,
well,
the difference is like when you have a
dream and you have this incredible dream
or a unicorn comes out of the clearing
in the forest and like a rainbow shoots
out of it's worn,
and then it turns into a swarm of
fireflies that spell I love you.
Well,
that's like,
you know,
that's a really cool dream,
right?
But that's not real.
That didn't happen.
And it's completely different than if
you went into a clearing,
uh,
and,
and saw a fucking Unicorn because if you
can go into clearing and see a fucking
Unicorn,
tell me where the clearing is.
Let's get some nets.
Another thing too about,
well,
here's the thing about mushrooms,
mushrooms enough to stop and think about
the people that wrote the Bible.
Stop to think about the people that have
discovered mushrooms a long time ago by
trial and error,
or whatever the method was.
And imagine everybody decided to get
together in some field somewhere and you
all take these mushrooms and you all
literally go to heaven and you have this
insane experience.
And then you all come back and then you
have to write about it in your ancient
tongue.
You have to write this down in Aramaic
on animal skins.
You roll these up and put them in clay
jars in the caves of Qumran so that
someone someday will know this and
understand what you've been through.
Well,
when the drought came,
the mushrooms went away and we were left
with nothing but stories mean you have
to repeat the craziest thing about
psychedelics,
especially the natural ones that don't
kill anybody.
Is it somehow or another somebody wound
up bing enough people and putting off
disinformation out that one of the most
valuable things ever in for human
exploration ever as far as like the
exploration of our mind is the
one,
one of the most valuable things that's
ever existed for changing the way you
view the world,
giving you a reset.
The one though and doesn't kill anybody,
it's illegal.
It's illegal in societies that are
oriented in a way that that would be
corrosive.
Right?
And that's,
that's why getting into legal,
what's legal in Peru and
they just decriminalized lsd.
And what is it,
Sweden?
Where do they do?
I think it was a switcher go.
Everything's legal.
Yeah,
Portugal's got it nailed.
I think in Sweden they made it a
misdemeanor to.
I can't remember somewhere recently.
They just made it a misdemeanor to have
to get caught with asset on the books
for the 2018 elections for California.
We have to organize like,
this is something we really should
really should go after this.
Like if you want to talk to me people,
Oh God,
that's going to go after military rooms.
Don't you really could change the world
and this is not bullshit.
If we organized and we got a bunch of
people to vote yes,
on recreational use of mushrooms for
adults,
I literally think we could change the
world.
That would be the best.
It could change the world because like
medical marijuana,
it will spread to recreational marijuana
and recreational mushrooms get past and
if they do medical mushrooms get passed
and then they can start doing tests on
mushrooms.
Like the John Hopkins psilocybins
studies that they've done.
You would see literally a change in the
world.
You would see a shift in global
consciousness and that's not.
That's not a ridiculous thing to say.
It's probably true.
Well,
that's why Tim scully and his partner
made all that orange sunshine acid.
They weren't.
I had him on my podcast.
He's such a sweet guy.
I'm not interested in money.
He could have made tons of money doing
other things.
He was this child genius and he just
made the acid and went to prison for it
because he wanted to change the world.
He really thought it would do it.
Know I've been talking to you through
email to William Leonard Pickard.
That dude who got busted with all that
acid.
He's in jail now for like a multiple
life sentences.
When they busted him,
he is the guy that was like the missile
silo that.
Oh yeah.
Was the guy that had the girl that lived
with them and they were selling ecstasy
and someone tried to kill somebody or
something.
It's so crazy.
Someone got.
The other guy got arrested.
That girl Rad the guy out and holy shit,
there's a great book he wrote.
If you want to read it,
really trippy book,
he wrote this book called the Rose of
paraklesis and it's this really cool
book and it's kind of like flow.
It's very intense to read and the way
it's written,
it's really not.
But um,
uh,
it's pretty interesting.
It's talking about sort of the life of
a,
it's a,
the setup is a guy's going to talk to an
lsd chemist and a who is sort of
explaining what it's like to have to be
a secret as you have to be if you're
manufacturing what he calls planetary
doses of Lsd,
which is what they want planetary.
And that's
what they wanted to do.
That was the idea is like let's
manufacturer planetary doses of this
substance to up shift the consciousness
of the planet.
And one of the things he says,
it's all very flowery and beautiful,
but he's talking about the lsd chemist
and people being like,
this is a for profit thing.
And he's saying,
no,
you know,
for us money is,
is just the ability to move around.
Because when you're an lsd chemist,
and again,
it's all very flowery writing,
but he says something along the lines of
when you're standing next to the forge
of the gods,
you stop thinking about money as meaning
anything because you're breathing in the
fumes.
You're broke.
You're like constantly in contact with
this,
like mind expanding substance.
And good luck when you're mid,
you know,
200 microgram trip.
Good luck taking money seriously.
And that moment is this fucking Shit,
man.
This stuff's ridiculous.
You know?
So,
so,
um,
yeah man,
there was,
there still is,
I hope,
I don't know if there is,
but there are people who are
manufacturing psychedelics and putting
their entire lives at risk,
not because they want to make money.
And it could be,
maybe they started off wanting to make
money,
but now that they're manufacturing it
because they know of all the ways to
shift human consciousness,
there's lots of ways theoretically to do
it,
you know,
can you imagine being the person who's
responsible for literally like a
swimming pool filled with acid that will
change the world.
Like,
you know,
like right in front of you.
If you could get this,
there would be such a hiccup and shift
of culture.
I mean,
I don't know which way it would go.
I don't know what would happen.
I don't know how much schizophrenia you
would trigger.
I don't know how many people would blow
fuses.
I don't know,
but I do know that something would
happen and it will know about shy evil
times when this happened based or God,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
That's what they think happened with the
Salem witch trials that literally the
Erg gotten the Rod because of an early
frost.
Some new fungus had grown on some of the
bread and they were able to run tests on
it and they believe that it has lsd like
property to it.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's the,
uh,
that's certainly one of the potential
ways to like upshift consciousness,
Epi,
getting people having access to
psychedelics in a consensual way.
You know,
like when you're fucking chomping
polluted wheat and suddenly think your
neighbors know fucking Satan.
Pretty scared.
That's,
that's different than like deciding to
take a psychedelic in a responsible way
and then understanding a little bit more
about how to be compassionate or
something like that,
you know,
seeing yourself for the first time.
I remember seeing yourself though.
The first time I took mushrooms I saw
myself and I was like,
oh yeah,
that's who I am.
You know,
like you before you do it,
it's like you have this idea looking in
out and then you are separated from all
of your life and you're like this entity
observing from the outside your life
yourself is the first time I ever
considered myself outside of myself.
Dude,
this is.
I'm sorry.
I was bringing up Rhonda us on your
podcast.
A lot of them,
but one of the grading under his beads,
one of the great stories is one of the
great stories is that,
uh,
you know,
he gave Lsd to Neem Karoli Baba,
his guru twice,
first time,
and you can find a youtube video of him
telling the story.
It's amazing.
It gives him like,
you know,
Owsley,
Owsley kid,
Charlemagne has given him this
incredible lsd.
Says it's 300 microgram tablets made by
one of the great lsd chemist of our time
and he's going to need to give it to
people and he gives it to.
He gives a 600 micrograms to Neem Karoli
Baba.
Now 600 micrograms is like,
fuck that.
Fuck that.
That's just too much.
And neem Karoli Baba eats it.
But the way he's eating it,
as he's like doing this,
throwing it in his mouth and eats it,
nothing happens.
So Rom das gets back to the United
States.
He's telling one of his scientists,
friends,
this store and a science friends,
come on,
dude.
He didn't fucking eat it.
He threw,
he palmed it.
He threw it over his shoulder.
This story is bullshit.
You got tricked.
You got hoodwinked by fucking Bob out in
India.
They're all out there.
They just want you to worship.
Then they want you to think they're
powerful.
So like Rhonda is,
gets back to India the second time with
acid again.
And this guy named Karoli Baba says to
him,
when you were here last time,
what did you give me around us as says,
well,
I gave you lsd.
And he's like,
did I take it around?
The US is like,
I don't know,
and he's like,
give me more,
give me more.
So it gives him more.
And he takes these pills,
puts them in his mouth,
chewing them up in front of him and
opens his mouth.
His mouth is coated with tablet acid.
He's taken a coordinator around us now,
900 Mike's of this stuff.
And so he goes under his blanket and
starts shaking.
And I know people now,
I've seen you saw this happen,
not just him telling the story,
who saw it happen?
And they said like,
the fucking blood rushed out around us,
his face.
He's like,
oh my God.
Oh my God,
what have I done?
What was I fucking thinking?
I just drove this dude crate.
I essentially just gave an old man 900
micrograms of fucking acid in the hills
of India and he's going to go fucking
nuts and it's going to be my fault.
Right?
And so,
like,
neem Karoli Baba comes out of the
blanket,
his eyes are back in his head,
he's like,
and then he just goes back to completely
normal,
nothing,
no effect.
And he says to him,
so was he,
was he laughing what now he was putting
on?
He was playing on a fuck.
He was playing a joke to fuck with him,
but he,
but,
uh,
he was just fucking with.
But what,
what,
uh,
what he said to him was really
interesting.
We said to him,
was this,
he said,
we used it.
They used to have something like this in
the Indus Valley and he said,
uh,
this will bring you into the presence of
Christ,
but you have to leave better
to become Christ than to hang out with
him.
He said,
which is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was his.
Because their premise was,
this is something like,
this is definitely a thing for sure.
But there could be that thing.
Yeah.
That's it.
That was the,
you can live there.
Yeah.
I think that we're entirely in prison
divide a wall of ideas and of behavior
and a momentum.
And of culture and of conditioning and
the way we look at the world is like in
these preprogram trunks,
that's a car that's a building we,
I don't think necessarily we see it for
what it really completely is,
which is some very strange temporary
life that no one has really defined the
meaning of it.
We're,
we're in infinity hurling through space
surrounding and giant nuclear explosion
rocketing through the universe and all
of that.
Trying to make,
make sense of it all,
and in between there you've got cops
killing people in hallways.
You've got black lives matter,
you've got a.
you've got every single possible
variation from furries to people that
it's their job to ticket street vendors
who don't have the right.
It'd be the whole thing is this entire
thing that we're experiencing is really
psychedelic.
If you weren't living life and if life
made way more sense,
like in the world that we're normally
accustomed to,
is much more controlled and two
dimensional,
and you could see the world that we live
in for the very first time.
You'd be overwhelmed by how insane it
is.
You'd be overwhelmed by the
possibilities.
We'd be overwhelmed by the Internet.
You'd be overwhelmed by language.
You'd be overwhelmed by feelings and
emotions and all of it.
If we weren't used to it,
all of it will be like,
whoa,
this is crazy.
Like nonverbal expression.
People Strip clubs for race cars,
all of it planes.
Why don't they have metal tubes?
They flying through the air,
the fuck.
We're just so used to all of it.
That life itself is very psychedelic.
It's just a psychedelic experience that
we've grown deeply accustomed to and I
think the psychedelic experience that
you have when you're on a heavy duty
thing,
like a dmt,
it's like you venture forth into a
dimension that you don't have context
for,
but you feel familiar.
You feel familiar with it,
but you don't have context for it.
It doesn't fit into your normal
patterns,
but the normal patterns are just as
bizarre.
Man.
The normal patterns were taking liquid.
How do these clear plastic things that
are made out of oil that somehow the
other they figured out to turn into a
clear plastic.
Can we fill it up with liquids and you
drink them?
The Chuck?
These things and you follow the path of
this plastic bottle,
it might eventually wind up in some
seagulls gut choking to death in the
middle of the ocean.
You know,
I mean,
it's bizarre,
but then also add to that that you're
melting into time to while you drink
from the bottle,
you're just not.
The
insanity that is bottle is like your
bottles mid process it somewhere from
some batch of gooey shit to being a
bottle to being in a seagulls.
Got You're mid process to honey,
you're getting funding getting
dissolved,
you know what I mean?
You're mid process and and,
and like the sun and so is the fucking
sun.
But you know,
the fun thing to do,
this is something that occurred to me
when I was super high recently.
I was sitting in this fucking apartment
and then suddenly it dawned on me like,
wait a minute,
how many other people are going to
fucking live here?
And then I'm thinking like,
wait,
how many people have lived here?
And then I'm thinking,
how many conversations have happened in
this fucking apartment where everybody
thought these were really serious
conversations.
Like,
Oh yeah,
we're really getting into it,
man,
and then you realize,
oh my God,
I'm just a little.
I'm just a little eddy of air spinning
around in this fucking apartment.
I'm going to leave and there's going to
be other little eddies of hair that spin
around in this apartment.
The apartment's going to be around way
longer than any of those other eddies of
air.
So really just to add to what you're
saying,
the beauty of the glorious nature of the
universe versus our ability to
comprehend it is that we are so fucking
impermanent.
We are so impermanent and we are so
fluid and we're so melting into time.
It's a really amazing thing that will
allow you and I and you say you say
we're used to it and sometimes I think,
yeah,
that must be it,
but I think also there's a lot of eggs.
We're ignoring it.
We're numb to it.
It's too much.
Too overwhelmed.
Yes.
You think about hunter gatherers,
hunter gatherers lived in the world that
created them,
the world that they evolved in,
right?
So it's the same world.
Your father and grandfather and great
grandfather.
Everybody lived in the same world,
so the skills you're born learning,
I grew up learning.
Those are the skills that are
appropriate to your world where we're in
a world now where even people who are
alive are in a different world than the
one they were born into.
You know,
and where I grew up before the Internet,
right.
This is all new.
I was in my thirties when the shit
started.
Yeah.
So nuts and.
But people,
younger people can't imagine what it was
like to travel before there was email.
Yeah.
So you were like 40 when the first
iphone came out,
right?
I was born in [inaudible].
Sixty two.
Yeah.
So the whole thing is,
it's hard to imagine it being any
different than it is,
but if you really just think of what it
is,
I'll either,
just the discussions that we've had here
today about what the potential issues
could be with ai,
with advancing technology that has not
been mapped out.
It's not,
it's not going to be regulated as far as
how far innovation is allowed to
continue.
It's not going.
They're going to.
They're going to be so far ahead of the
people that understand the regulations.
Let's get that.
Things are going to be coming out like
the Internet itself.
The Internet came out itself before they
really understood what the implications
were.
If the government could go back in time
and pull the fucking,
hey,
pop.
Let's talk about this first.
Pull that plug right out of the wall
before the Internet on aol
and let's just talk about what we're
going to do with this and let's,
let's manage this because let me show
you what it could be,
and then you'd see 25 years later,
people like holding on their phones,
walking into traffic and getting hit by
cars because they're so addicted to
checking their facebook fan,
man.
Yeah,
it's nuts.
Yeah.
Imagine if a drug could do with cell
phones.
Do imagine if a drug came along and the
drug made you like stare at your hands
all day,
that everybody was just like staring at
their hands.
It means like praying.
Yeah.
The only.
The only thing difference is you are
getting some information,
but I mean if there was a drug that came
along that made you want to stare at
your hands like 90 percent of the day,
like if you're playing video games,
you're not getting any information.
That's true.
Porn.
Well they say the video games in some
ways are good for the site though.
Good for the psyche.
They make it good for your mind.
Pilots.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
it's not good for my psyche getting my
fucking ass kicked at hearthstone where
this new expansion.
But very quickly the thing you're
talking about the um,
the uh,
the,
the concept of a drug that makes you
stare at your hands.
I think our thoughts at one point like
the ability to think the way we do was a
new technology.
It started emerging.
And so like when you're caught up in
your thoughts,
what's the difference between that and
looking at your fucking cell phone?
Like when you get obsessed with your
thoughts and like,
cause I've noticed like whenever I get
really caught up in a flurry of thoughts
and I allow myself to really get lost in
the thing you're talking about the
simulation,
the projection into the future.
You're 17 fights ahead with this person
because they said this thing that
they're never going to say.
I think that's a form of looking at your
cell phone only.
It's the internal simulator inside the
neuro computer that your brain is,
but I don't think it's too much
different.
I think both of these things are just
different attempts to try to evade the
present moment because the present
moment is so overwhelmingly
heartbreakingly beautiful that we'd
rather have our faces buried in our
phones or in our thoughts.
I think that's the problem is the more
that we get into the moment,
it's fucking amazing here.
It is amazing,
but I don't think that's what's.
I don't think it's the fact that it's
beautiful that's making people be
distracted.
I think overwhelming the amount of data
that's coming our way and I don't think
we're designed for it.
I think that's one of the things that
gets people at peace.
If you're on a hike in nature,
this is all stuff where your brain has a
whole fort.
We're talking about keys,
keys at slots.
Those key is just fit in.
There's a tree,
there's the bird,
all of that eagle.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Look,
the salmon jumping,
that's there's keys for that.
There's receptors for all that stuff.
When you're walking down fucking Santa
Monica Boulevard and his people honking
their horn and different music is
playing in different cars and there's
smells that aren't natural and there's
so much data coming your way.
It's overwhelming and then you're
thinking about your work and your job
and your boss keeps giving you massages.
Creepy.
You know?
You just want to.
When it gets back to that natural,
unnatural conversation we began with,
right?
Because you know you're.
You're describing the metaphor of
receptor cells or something for these
different inputs,
but another way to look at it is your
body has expectations,
right?
Your eyes are designed with an
expectation of certain wavelengths of
light that are relevant to this animal,
right?
Those are like the reds of the berries
are relevant because now they're ripe
and you know there are different than
blood is shocking and all that.
The ears are expectations of certain
decibel levels that would be important
for this animal to hear.
Rabbits I've totally different setup,
you know,
so your whole body,
your lungs or an expectation of oxygen,
rich air,
you know everything.
And when you take that animal out,
it's confused because what it's
expecting isn't there.
So it's not just metaphorical,
it's,
it's actually physiologically we're
living in a world that our bodies don't
expect.
Hmm.
God Damn.
What a great way to end this thing
sitting for five hours.
This was fun.
Jesus Christ.
Thank you guys.
Let's do this more often.
Make these easy.
We can all just will triple cast it.
You want to do that while three?
Put it out,
put it.
We'll do that.
Whatever time.
I think that's probably the best way to
do it all the time.
Yeah.
So that way nobody has to miss any of
them or not subscribed.
And um,
you guys are both here.
Now you're here,
you're moving back.
I'm back,
you're done and you're here.
So unless I get kidnapped and Peru and a
little bit more often,
there's some of my favorite podcast ever
that Chris Ryan on twitter and the
instagram.
Same.
Same beckers and Duncan trussell and
everything.
I can trust them.
Alright fuckers.
Thank you.
Bye.